Okay, good morning.
We are ready.
So Linda, do you want to start?
I will do so.
Seeing that all board members are now present, Karen Stepwalters, will you please call the roll to establish quorum?
Yes, good morning.
Sue Burr?
Here.
Linda Darling-Hammond?
Matt Navo?
Here.
Brenna, Peg, Jolene.
Patricia Rucker.
Here.
Eileen Strauss.
Tim Sun.
All present.
All right.
I hereby call the May 2020 meeting of the State Board of Education to order.
And we will commence as usual by saluting the flag.
Vice President Strauss, will you please lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance?
Would you all please rise?
We're going to get the flag on screen.
Right hand over your heart.
Ready?
Begin.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the Republic for which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Thank you.
So this is going to be our first and probably not our last state board meeting by Zoom.
We will be all aware and gracious with one another if the doorbell rings, if the dog barks, if something else happens in our homes.
And I'm going to start now with our announcements.
I'd like to first of all announce with pleasure that Deborah Brown has joined the State Board of Education Office as a Senior Policy Advisor.
She will advise on policy and legislation by working with California interest groups in the legislature, coordinate the legislative related activities for the State Board Office.
She comes to the
SBE with over 20 years of experience in a variety of organizations, working on behalf of California's public schools, children and youth.
Her most recent experiences include working for Children Now on K-12 and early learning policy and advocacy, and serving as the Director of the Government Affairs Division at the CDE.
I don't know if she can pop in so we can see her or not.
She's not in, she's not here.
She's not in the state boardroom.
She's with us remotely.
Okay, well, we welcome her and we're thrilled that she's with us.
Attachment two of item three, the summary of public comments for the federal funding flexibility waiver is provided as an addendum.
The proposed waiver consent items
are W01 through W12.
The proposed regular consent items are six through 11.
We will take up both the waiver consent items and regular consent items later today.
For public input, members of the public that wish to dial in for public comment should view the live stream of the meeting to know at what time we will ask for public comment for each item on the agenda.
Public comment may be provided
by dialing the phone number and participant access code, and then following each of the operator's prompts.
Upon dialing in, the callers will be asked for a caller queue.
The operator will notify callers when it is their turn to provide public comment.
We'll also ask the public calling in for public comments to please turn down the speaker volume of their computers if they're following the live feed so that they don't get an echoing effect.
Public comment will be limited to one minute
for each speaker.
Item 13 is the general public comment item during which members of the public may provide comment on items that are not specifically listed on the board's agenda.
I'm gonna ask the board members to please mute your microphones when you're not speaking.
Keep your cameras on at all times except during the scheduled breaks to ensure that we maintain a quorum throughout today's virtual meeting.
For each item on the agenda, there will be an opportunity for board members to raise your hand using the Zoom participant window if you'd like to ask a question or make a comment.
And I'll be keeping an eye on that as well, Karen, to make sure that we are alert to who's trying to get into the conversation.
And now I'd like to invite State Superintendent Tony Thurmond to provide the superintendent's report.
Thank you, Madam President.
Good morning, Madam President and board members and to those who are participating in this board meeting virtually.
As you all know, our school's campuses have been closed to students and that they took that action shortly after March 13th with the governor's executive order, creating the flexibility
for our students to be served during distance learning.
Our school districts continue to provide all the supports that our students need.
More than 5,000 locations providing meals to students.
I want to acknowledge the resiliency of our students, of our staff, and their parents for the hard work that they are doing under the most difficult circumstances that you might imagine.
The California Department of Education, working closely with the State Board of Education, has been providing guidance to our school districts on how to serve students in distance learning.
We provide three webinars every single week on topics like serving English learners and how to deliver special education through distance learning.
We also provide virtual support circles for parents.
We've launched a series of virtual supports for parents who feel stress and overwhelmed with all the requirements of aiding and supporting their children while they're at home and learning at home.
Today, we're launching the first in a virtual support circle series of support for educators.
And as it is Teacher Appreciation Week, we wanna acknowledge and thank our hardworking teachers and educators who are supporting our students in their districts.
We've launched a number of task forces to help us address the needs of our students.
We still have a million students in our state who do not have access to the Internet.
And our staff has been surveying every district on their needs for students to have a computing device at home.
Our data shows that 400,000 students have an immediate need for having a device at home.
And so we're really pushing internet service providers
and companies to make donations of equipment and resources that will support our students.
Our own State Board President has made numerous calls that has resulted in a number of donations to help provide computing equipment and hotspots for our students, but there's much more that needs to be done.
We are very concerned about learning gaps that many students might experience as a result of
either time away from any formal education.
Some of our school districts needed time to ramp up for distance learning.
And so there was a period where there wasn't anything being offered until teachers could get trained in materials.
can get deployed.
The good news is every district is now engaged in very robust and meaningful distance learning.
But we know that there had been an achievement gap even before the impacts of COVID-19.
And so we're concerned about how those learning gaps get exacerbated.
And we have declared a task force focused on addressing the loss of learning and how do we support our students.
We are actively working hard on answering the question on how can our schools reopen safely when the time is right and when there's an all clear for schools to do so.
We've also named a task force that is looking at things like health and safety needs.
and how staff will be arranged and how we'll continue to have some social distancing in schools and to make sure that we have all the personal protective equipment that our students need.
And so the California Department of Education is continuing to provide support to educators and students and their families.
We've appreciated the great work with the State Board President and the State Board of Education staff.
Education continues, even in these difficult challenges, and we're going to continue to make sure that every one of our students gets a great education here in the state of California.
This completes my report.
Thank you, and thanks to you, Tony, and to the CDE staff and the State Board staff who have been working 24-7 around the clock just to, you know,
make it possible for our large state to mount distance learning, to teach kids, to make sure that families are served.
It's been a very intense time and the staff have been unbelievable and we appreciate that leadership.
I also want to echo those thanks, and this is National Teacher Appreciation Week, and I of course want to thank all of our teachers who are working so hard in this time of crisis.
Schools may be physically closed, but education is continuing in California.
Students are still learning and that's because teachers are still working very hard to provide quality instruction.
They say that necessity is the mother of invention and we have seen that in many, many ways over this last few weeks.
as so many creative and innovative ideas have surfaced as we've been shifting to distance learning.
We've seen everything from virtual classrooms that incorporate multimedia platforms, to teachers driving to students' houses to work out math problems on whiteboards outside their window, to the drive-by, grab-and-go meals.
Teachers have been thinking imaginatively to transcend the hurdles of the digital divide
as well as stepping up to provide a lot of social and emotional support.
So I want to thank the teachers for your love, your encouragement, your patience.
I want to also acknowledge the hard work of school support staff and administrators, nutrition service workers,
who are keeping our students fed.
Everyone involved in getting laptops and Wi-Fi out to our students so they can connect with their teachers.
And you know who you are, managing that huge logistics undertaking.
Thanks to all the schools that are providing safe childcare spaces for essential workers.
And a special shout out to the folks who are working in our high schools.
May and June are traditionally times of great joy on high school campuses as staff celebrates honors and proms and graduations and assemblies.
And even though those are not taking place in the usual way, we are seeing some wonderful out-of-the-box ideas for celebrating the class of
2020.
Many of them are developed by the students themselves as they are taking leadership and making decisions about the close of the school year in many communities.
Communities are honoring our graduates by putting up lawn signs with seniors' photos, renting billboards, holding car parades, porch proms, virtual college signing days,
Senior portfolio defenses are occurring online as students present their projects to audiences within and outside the school.
They're recognized for the quality of their research.
Zoom commencements are also being planned.
We know it's not the same, but celebration takes many forms and we will find many creative ways to recognize the courage and the determination of our students and our teachers and educators and parents.
It has been really heartening to see the education community come together despite the many challenges we have faced.
California was one of the first states to mount distance learning and seek to address both the new pedagogies and the digital divide.
We've probably closed the digital divide in California by half, or as Tony said, we have a long way to go and we're committed to completing that work.
California issued guidance and resources in March that have been taken up by many other states.
The people in CDE and CCEE and the county offices and the district offices and schools have designed all kinds of professional development to support school staff who are to be thanked as well.
The work is highly variable and it's far from perfect, but we've come a long way in a very short time.
and the journey continues.
As you know, like many other states, California applied for and was granted waivers from federal testing and accountability requirements this year.
We will, however, continue to collect data that will be available to communities in the fall.
The LCAP process has been moved to the fall so community engagement can occur.
People can take stock of where they are and make plans
And the three-year LCAP planning cycle will shift to 2021 to 2024, so we can take into account the new realities that have occurred as we plan.
We're beginning to move from Stage 1 in the state's process for managing COVID, which is establishing safety and preparedness.
to stage two, which is reopening low-risk businesses.
As you know, Governor Newsom announced on Monday that certain stores can start offering curbside pickups, some construction can start back up, some further modifications to the stay-at-home order are coming soon.
And this does raise the question of when schools may reopen.
And there's a sense of urgency to address learning loss that may have occurred.
Depending on how health indicators
unfold in different parts of the state.
It will be potentially possible for some districts that are prepared to do so, and they get a green light from their county health departments to engage in person-to-person summer school to re-engage students this summer.
in year-round school where that is the norm or to invite some students back to school early.
And these decisions will all be made through the lens of public health and local stakeholder input as that is the prime consideration.
There are a number of health indicators that the administration has laid out that have to be met before schools reopen.
the capacity for widespread testing and contract tracing, sufficient PPE.
Hospitals have to have the capacity to handle surges.
We have to be able to prevent infection in people who are at risk for more severe infection.
Before that happens, guidance, as the superintendent mentioned, will be issued about how to maintain health and safety in schools.
We'll be prepared for the possibility that we may have to open school and then close it again and then reopen it again.
And we'll need to be prepared for blended learning models, for a more seamless transition that ensures the prospects for learning, even if the places for learning are variable.
The state will continue to provide guidance as needed to help local agencies work through these challenges.
We'll continue to apply to the Department of Education for the waivers and assistance that we need.
We will continue to advocate for more money from the federal government in the next Recovery Act.
which is under construction in Washington right now.
We'll work with the state legislature, which is coming back into session, as they will play a critical role, most immediately in adopting the state budget.
And we'll continue our role together in guiding policy to reflect the realities of this pandemic.
As the governor said, we will get through this, but we have to get through it together.
So with that, we're going to move on now to agenda number one in the mega assessment item.
And this item is going to be presented by Mal Vang of the CDE.
Mal, are you there?
I am.
You may begin.
OK.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
OK.
And we can see your slide.
All right, well, thank you very much.
Good morning, Superintendent Thurmond, President Darling-Hammond, and board members.
I'm Mao Vang, the Director of Assessment, Development, and Administration Division.
Before I jump right into the item, I would like to just take a moment in celebration of Teacher Appreciation Week and continuing a tradition of our former Deputy Superintendent Kerrick Ashley started for the May meetings.
To thank a teacher who has impacted me.
And I would like to thank Ms.
Swanson who taught me English as a second language in fourth grade.
And although I came to the U.S.
as a young child and did not know any English, she instilled in me the joy of learning English.
Yes, there is such a thing.
And she also encouraged me to have confidence and command the language.
And that is in part why I am able to be here with you today to present on the English Language Assessments for California.
So thank you, Ms.
Watson.
And then moving on to my item here, I would like to remind that the item before you today is both an action and an information item.
And I will begin with the action item recommendations.
So today, the California Department of Education, CDE, recommends that the California State Board of Education, SBE, approve the following.
The proposed alternate English language proficiency assessments for California, or LPAC test blueprint, as found in attachment two, and authorization for CDE staff to make technical edits as necessary.
I will provide some background information and go over the alternate LPAC timeline of development activities.
In June 2018, in section 141A of Assembly Bill 1808, it was approved and it provided funding for the development of a computer-based alternate English language proficiency assessment for students with disabilities.
From there, we took the high-level test design of the alternate LPAC to the board for approval last May 2019.
Then in preparation for the proposed test blueprint, the alternate LPAC pilot and cognitive lab was administered in January 2020.
The preliminary findings from the pilot and cognitive lab supported the identification of the specific task types included in the proposed test blueprint.
Today we will bring that proposed alternate LPAC test blueprint to the board for approval.
And upon approval, the test blueprint will be used to develop the alternate LPAC census and SEAL test items and forms, which will be administered to all eligible students in January through February of 2021.
Then in May 2021, after standard setting has been completed in late February or early March, the proposed threshold scores will be brought to the State Board of Education for approval.
And finally, on July 1st, 2021, is when the alternate LPAC will become fully operational, starting with the initial assessment.
This is an excerpt of the proposed test blueprint for the alternate LPAC in Table 1 of Attachment 2 in the board item.
So the first column provides you with a list of task types.
There are seven task types for each
grade or grade span.
Only two are shown here, recognize and use common words and communicate about familiar topics.
In the second column, the linguistic complexity level is identified for each task type of low, medium, or high.
And in the third column, the test questions or items within a task type are aligned to one or more primary and secondary English language development connectors, which are found in the next two columns.
Each of these connectors are aligned with the 2012 California English Language Development Standards.
The test blueprint also includes the number of items for each task type and the associated points which are in the next column.
The test blueprint also identifies the four domains, listening and reading, and speaking and writing.
as shown by the receptive and expressive item counts and points column.
In addition, the test blueprint ensures that English learners with the most significant cognitive disabilities can fully access and participate in the alternate LPAC.
Students may use this
But students may use their individually preferred receptive and expressive communication modes to respond to each of the task types.
So this design helps to ensure that maximum participation of all eligible test takers will be available.
So the CDE did collect feedback from a variety of stakeholders beginning in August 2019 through February of 2020.
The first group of stakeholders were our test design advisory team of national experts who included Dr.
Dean Sato of the Sato Education Consultant, and she's a chief research scientist there.
Dr. Lucretia Santibanez, Associate Professor at the UCLA Graduate School of Education and Information Studies.
Dr. Martha Thurlow, Senior Research Associate of the National Center on Educational Outcomes.
And Dr. Megan Covona,
Kovonen, Director of the Accessible Teaching, Learning, and Assessment Systems of the University of Kansas.
These national experts have expertise with English learner students and students with disabilities and large-scale assessments for students with disabilities.
The LPAC Technical Advisory Group also reviewed and gave feedback on the blueprint in November.
And then a small group of California special education and English learner educators participated in a virtual educator blueprint review.
In addition, members of the English learner support division and the special education division collaborated with the assessment division staff and provided feedback on the alternate OPAC test blueprint on several occasions during its development.
So with that, I'm going to pause here to answer any clarifying questions that you may have about the recommendation.
And while we are, before we take clarifying questions, I want to announce that members of the public who wish to provide comments on this item can do so by calling this number 712-432-0075.
712-432-0075 and enter the access code 651-905-FOUND.
Follow the operator prompts to hit star six and one to enter the queue.
And so while we're waiting for members of the public to call in, we can take any clarifying questions.
I first want to ask Ting Sun if she has any initial comments.
I don't have any initial comments at this point.
OK, thank you.
Great, the numbers are now up on that's terrific.
OK, are there any clarifying questions from members of the board before we go to public comment?
All right, seeing no hands raised, do we have
public comment prepared to begin?
There is currently no one signed up for public comment.
OK, if there is no public comment, then we will go ahead to further board discussion and remember to raise your hand in the participant area if you want to be recognized.
Is there any board discussion?
No, there's no board discussion.
Seeing none, I'm going to ask for a motion.
Do I have a motion?
Yeah, I will move CDE's recommendation and I should have said this earlier maybe that I know there are a lot of unanswered questions at this point regarding assessments to California.
I do appreciate
Mao and her team continuing the work in this area.
We definitely need to continue to forge ahead, even through the unknown at this point, and I just want to thank them for their work.
I'll second.
Second the emotion and the motion.
That's great.
Is there any further discussion?
Seeing none, all in favor, we're going to take a roll call vote.
So Karen, will you do the roll call?
Okay.
Members Sun?
Aye.
Strauss?
Rucker?
Aye.
Pangilinan?
Navo?
Aye.
Darling-Hammond?
Burr?
Aye.
Patio-Bronson?
Okay, it's unanimous.
All right, thank you, Mal.
So, Linda, Mal's not actually, that was the only, that was the action part of her item, but she still has the info part, correct, Mal?
Yes, I still have the assessment program updates.
Yes.
And then we'll do that short demo during my program updates.
Okay, terrific.
Take it away.
All right.
Thank you.
Okay, so first in terms of our program updates, I'd like to begin with a quick summary of Governor Gavin Newsom's recent executive orders that relate to statewide testing.
So on March 18, 2020, Governor Gavin Newsom issued Executive Order N3020 announcing California's intent to pursue a federal waiver of testing requirements.
And the purpose of the waiver of annual statewide assessments was for local educational agencies to take appropriate actions to mitigate the effects of the COVID-19 threat at that time.
And then on March 19, 2020, Governor Newsom's Executive Order N3020 communicated a statewide order for Californians to stay home or at their place of residence to protect the health and well-being of all Californians.
On March 20,
The CDE suspended all statewide CASP, summative LPAC, and the California High School proficiency examination testing.
Recently, on April 23rd, Governor Newsom issued Executive Order N5620, which waived the administration of the physical fitness test and data collection for the 2019-2020 school year.
Briefly, on the federal waiver on March 26, 2020, the State Superintendent of Public Instruction, Tony Thurmond, and the SBE President, Linda Darling-Hammond, submitted on behalf of the CDE and the SBE a federal waiver for the 2019-2020 school year.
The waiver request included the assessment requirements of the Elementary and Secondary Education Act.
And it also included the accountability and school identification requirements.
and reporting requirements related to assessments and accountability.
This waiver was approved by the U.S.
Department of Education on March 27 and includes the assessments of English language arts, mathematics, science, and English language proficiency.
The public comment period for the federal waiver ended on April 15, and this topic will be discussed further in item three, so I will move on.
So with the federal testing waiver in place, California educators will not have access to summative assessment data for all students.
So however, providing this graphic from Chapter 8 of the CDE's English Language Arts and EL English Language Development Framework, which shows how summative assessment is only one component of the assessment cycles that teachers use throughout the year to gauge student learning.
The students as presented on the left have the ultimate goal of understanding the standards on the right.
So let's consider how assessments cover different purposes.
One purpose is to use the formative assessments to inform teaching.
And formative assessments can occur minute by minute and daily.
Another purpose of assessments is to evaluate student learning after extended periods of learning have occurred.
These assessments would be like interim assessments and benchmark assessments, including curriculum and embedded assessments, such as weekly and unit assessments.
So these lead up to quarterly or annual summative assessments.
So what resources are available for educators to inform instruction?
Local educational agencies do have local control when it comes to what assessments they use to make decisions about instruction.
Here is what is available for our teachers to use in determining a student's knowledge levels.
They could use their own district or school-adopted assessment tools such as local district and school-wide benchmarks, district and school-adopted interim assessments, curriculum-embedded assessments, and district or school-adopted summative assessments.
At the state level, we provide the following resources, the option to utilize a grade two diagnostic assessment, the Smarter Balanced interim assessments for English Language Arts and Math, and statewide summative assessments in English Language Arts, Mathematics, Science, and English Language Proficiency.
With the widespread closure of schools across the state many LEAs are serving students through distance learning.
So to support teachers the CDE has made the Smarter Balanced Interim Assessments available for distance learning through June 30th as an optional resource.
The Smarter Balanced Interim Assessments are aligned to the Common Core State Standards and offer a way to measure student knowledge and practice in the academic language and vocabulary.
The CDE worked with Educational Testing Service, our contractor, to configure the test delivery system to eliminate the need for a secure browser on devices used by students.
In addition, the CDE provided local educational agencies with instructions for teachers as well as students and their parents or guardians to assist them in using the interim assessments for distance learning.
And the document for students is also available in Spanish.
Smarter Balanced has launched a new webpage for resources and suggestions on supporting and advancing distance learning.
And this is the Supporting Remote Teaching and Learning webpage link.
With that, another new feature is the tools for teachers will be the new formative assessment component of the Smarter Balanced assessment system that offers a suite of instructional and professional development resources.
At this point, I will pause and I'm going to have Tammy Saldana come up.
She will
provide a quick demo for us of the preview of the website for tools for teachers.
Thank you Mel.
Good morning, Superintendent Thurmond, President Darling-Hammond, and board members.
I'm Tammy Saldana, and I'm excited to show you this new resource coming soon from Smarter Balanced.
Since 2014, the digital library has featured formative assessment resources available to California educators and LEAs through our membership in the Smarter Balanced consortium.
However, the digital library will be decommissioned on May 28, 2020.
To make way for this new resource, I am showing you today called Tools for Teachers.
Tools for Teachers has been created to meet changing teacher needs as we have received educator input and feedback from LEAs.
In fact, hundreds of educators across the Smarter Balanced Consortium states, including California educators and CDE staff, have been working with Smarter Balanced over the past year to help create this new website of resources that will become the new formative assessment component of the Smarter Balanced assessment system.
This new website is an advanced suite of resources that focuses on implementing the formative assessment process in the classroom with resources that include embedded instructional differentiation with formative assessment and accessibility strategies.
In addition, this website and its resources meet accessibility standards because they are fully 508 compliant.
Today we have arranged access to the staging site for tools for teachers.
Smarter Balance is actively working on this website.
They have put their work on pause today just for us.
So let's take a look.
What you are seeing is the landing page here for Tools for Teachers.
The intended audience is four classroom teachers.
Every current digital library user will automatically have an account to use this website, as it will be available to all LEA staff with self-registration that is available for new users with an affiliated LEA email.
However, it's important to know that there are parts of Tools for Teachers that have public access where everyone can view.
I'll show you the public view first.
This landing page shows two full preview resources that can be entirely viewed without logging in.
It also has two videos, one for interim assessments and one for the formative assessment process.
At the top is a search bar for a keyword search, as well as a place to search by filters.
The resources and tools for teachers are instructional resources, professional learning resources, as well as groups of instructional resources called Connections Playlist.
A search can be also done by looking for formative assessment strategies and accessibility strategies that are embedded inside instructional resources.
There are filters by grade level, subject areas, claims, targets, and individual content standards.
I will search by grade six language arts.
Here you can see that the system has returned 72 resources.
As I said earlier, Smarter is still working on this website.
They are loading resources and preparing for the June 16th preview launch of Tools for Teachers.
On June 16th, many resources will be loaded and teachers will have access.
But the grand opening of Tools for Teachers is planned for the end of September.
Here, the user can scroll through the resource cards and see a summary.
I will select the resource Word Hunt.
We are still looking at public access.
In Tools for Teachers, all resources have a common structure.
Each resource has an overview with the lesson learning goal and the lesson success criteria.
Along the right, the user can see the claim, target, and individual content standards.
On the left are the sections of the resource.
In order to see the rest of the resource, this is where tools for teachers access becomes limited to those in California LEAs.
I will log in.
Take note that this resource I'm using was authored by a California educator.
Carol Bogie is a member of the California State Network of Educators.
Along the top is icons that teachers can use in order to take notes, share with their colleagues, bookmark, print, as well as expand and collapse the screen.
All resources have embedded instructional strategies for differentiating instruction to meet student needs.
There are formative assessment strategies in the resource wherever there is a clover icon in purple.
Formative assessment strategies are recommended ways for teachers to assess student progress at a moment of time during instruction.
And accessibility strategies are indicated by a silhouette of a person and are recommendations that offer ways for teachers to provide access for all students.
Every resource has a place for attachments that teachers can use to implement the resource, as well as a list of the accessibility strategies used, things to consider, a section where teachers are given recommendations for making the lesson effective, for example, how to extend the lesson, as well as how this resource fits into the formative assessment process.
This resource is a part of a group of resources that link to an interim assessment block.
These groups of resources are called playlists.
We are now looking at a connections playlist.
The title here, Language and Vocabulary Use,
is actually the name of an interim assessment block.
These playlists of resources are designed by groups of educators including California educators that write the instructional resources for a playlist with a focus on developing the skills needed to meet expected learning standards using the formative assessment process.
A teacher can take an interim assessment and use the connections playlist of resources to fill in any curriculum gaps or academic needs recognized when analyzing the interim assessments.
Each playlist has a section for the topics or skills listed on the left, performance progressions to see how students perform as they build the skills.
a section on the suggestions for intervention, things to consider, the interim assessment block background that's tied to these resources, the academic vocabulary are words that teachers can make sure that students know in order to answer the questions on the interim assessment block.
A Dive Deeper has a link to the Smarter Balanced resources that are available for educators, including the sample items website, as well as the content explorer.
And there's information about interim assessments and how to access them.
So that is Tools for Teachers in a nutshell.
Remember that the Smarter Balanced Digital Library will be decommissioned on May 28th.
The Tools for Teachers preview launches on June 16th.
The grand opening is planned for late September.
And also, the website that we will be using will be a California-specific instance of Tools for Teachers.
So we will be able to add other state-endorsed resources to this website for teachers to easily access resources from one website.
Now, I will turn it back over to Mal to continue our program updates.
Thank you.
Not yet.
OK, so thank you, Tammy.
We are looking forward to seeing the release of tools for teachers soon.
So now we also have another exciting development to share with you.
And in recognition of the formative assessment process and how it plays in the classroom supporting instruction and the need for science instructional resources,
The CDE along with the Sacramento County Office of Education has begun working with California science teachers to develop high quality science instructional resources aligned with the next generation science standards during two virtual workshops.
So the first workshop started on April 27th and it will end on May 20th with 10 science educators.
And the second virtual workshop will start in late May and finish in June with approximately 30 science educators as participants.
So by the end of June, we will have approximately 40 science instructional resources developed that can promote opportunities for three-dimensional science learning, emphasize hands-on activities that facilitate peer feedback and collaboration,
And they integrate common core state standards for ELA and mathematics, and also integrate formative assessment strategies and accessibility strategies.
So in addition to the resources developed, the CDE will include the resources from the five winners of the 2019 science, it's elementary contest.
And CDE is working with Smarter Balanced to arrange for the inclusion of these 40 new science resources on the Tools for Teachers website.
An update of the status of the effort will be provided in the Assessment Development and Administration Division's July 2020 SBE item.
One more thing, and speaking of science, I have an update on the California Science Test Alignment Study.
or CAST.
The California Science Test Independent Evaluator Contractor, which is a human resources research organization, or HUMRO, has completed the February or March 2019 CAST alignment study.
which was conducted with California educators, and the Lyman study indicated that the test forms were constructed in a manner that is consistent with the blueprint that was approved by the SBE in November 2017, and that the items were in line with the California Next Generation Science Standards.
So the final report will be posted in June on the CDE's CASP technical reports and studies website.
And the study will be submitted as part of the federal peer review in June of 2021.
And with that update, I will pause.
And that summarizes my presentation as well.
Great.
At this point, we don't have an action item, but if there are questions or comments that members of the board would like to make about any of the things that we've just heard, please let us know.
I see Member Navo, Member Patio-Bronson, and Member Strauss have raised their hands.
Matt, take it away.
Sure.
Mal, thank you for the report, and it's really helpful, and it's exciting to see all of the hard work that's been done.
So I appreciate that very much.
My question is, do we have a way to track what is being used in the area of tools for teachers or in regards to smarter balance assessments for distance learning?
In other words, would we be able to track what the highlights are being used from the field so that we can see what the area of emphasis or interest is?
Were you referring to having the Smarter Balanced interim assessments available to support distance learning?
And in the tools for teachers.
I know that's a little bit more complicated, but mainly the Smarter Balanced.
Yes, so we are making available the interim assessments right now to support and to be an option for distance learning usage.
So at this time we have maybe around 1,000 students who have taken the interim assessments remotely.
And in terms of the tools for teachers, it is in development.
So what we were seeing in the demonstration is really their preview site that they kind of stopped working on it for today so that we could do a demonstration of the content for you.
But certainly when it becomes available in June, I am sure that there is a mechanism to track teacher usage and access and we will make it available to all of our teachers who already have accounts.
And we do have about around 300,000 member accounts in the system.
Thank you, Mao.
That's great.
I think that would be something that would help inform our work and support to the field.
So I appreciate it.
Thank you for your question.
OK.
And I think Member Patia Bronson, you were next.
And I see Member Rucker has also raised her hand after Eileen Straus.
She will be next in line.
Thank you, Mel, for the very comprehensive report.
And also, a lot of these tools seem very exciting.
My question, I guess, relates to what Board Member Nava's question was around how the model is being
modified to encourage and enable this to be used in a in the context of distance learning with with the suspension of summative assessments at year end.
Obviously formative assessments take up more prominence.
And just thinking about how to support districts in actually using these tools in the context of distance learning which is new for everyone and
And just is that a big part of the rollout?
How is that moving forward?
Yes, so we did take time to work with our contractor to remove the requirement for the secure browser.
Usually when teachers and students are taking a test in a room, the students would take the test on a computer with a secure browser so that when they're taking the test, they don't have access to any other browsers to look up information.
However, we removed that component so that
students who are at home, the teachers could still administer any of the interim assessments, the comprehensive one, or even any of the interim assessment blocks remotely for the students to take, and they would not even need a secure browser on their computer.
piece of a challenge has been removed.
And that is why there's movement in people using it remotely.
Prior to that, that would not even happen.
Does that help address some things that we've done?
We've communicated with the field.
Also we did some directions handouts and we also for students and parents as well as teachers and we for the student versions as I mentioned earlier we translated them into Spanish as well so that if they should need it and they're at home hopefully they could be able to access it either in English or Spanish.
Is that also true for the Tools for Teacher website?
And I recognize that's not going to be launched until September.
But I think one of the things as I've been having conversations with folks here in the Southern California area is that there's very different levels of comfort with online collaboration and teaching and learning, which makes sense because it's new for everyone.
How is the tools for teacher website beyond sort of the security issue being modified to encourage online collaboration and teaching and learning?
So the tools for teachers is like a supplemental resource for teachers, right?
They have their own units and their own scope and sequence of how they're teaching their students.
applying their curriculum.
So they really need resources to supplement their teaching and learning opportunities.
And in there, as Tammy mentioned, there are opportunities for them to share resources with each other within the system.
So that's one way to collaborate with their peers.
They could also take notes within the system, and they could also print resources should they need to do that.
So there are little tools in there to help them access it in that way.
But however, it is a resource that California does pay for, so it is limited to our educators in the state of California.
California as well as other local educational agency staff as long as they have a district given or provided email account.
So I'm not sure if I addressed every what your specific question was so if I need to clarify something or bring someone in to clarify a component I'd be happy to.
I do have some key staff here.
Kim, do you feel?
That's helpful.
Thank you.
Okay, great.
So, Member Strauss, you're next.
So, actually, this is a follow-up to Member Patel-Bronson's comment about the rollout.
So, let me just say, there are so many
digital resources out there right now.
And first, I just want to thank Mal for the presentation.
I was actually on a call with the math science community who are working with CDE to try to help develop some of these materials.
And so as teachers are gaining some comfort, they're needing some specific content level resources.
So I know the CDE has been working really hard on that.
The tools for teachers I think is the next generation and it sounds like it's being curated for California and I really am excited about that.
We're going to have to help teachers and leaders navigate all the different digital resources out there because there are more webinars and tools and things going on.
And so I'm just wondering when we think about the rollout, which sounds like the grand rollout is late September,
And who knows if we'll be open or closing again by then.
So, I'm just wondering if we ought to think about the rollout with these leaders who helped develop it, but also the county offices, so that they can work in context with their local districts.
And maybe we need to think about not only highlighting what resources we have, but how to navigate it, so that it can be focused on
first priorities of lost learning, of the academic needs.
And I think the teachers are working to integrate, so showing how you can do literacy with science and connecting with math.
And it might be helpful if we use our curriculum leaders from a county office to help us maybe think through how to roll out tools for teachers in a way that helps people navigate.
Because
Really, it's going to be while they're driving the train and teaching their kids, they're going to get introduction to new resources.
So just like it took us a while to do the digital library and get that active.
I think as we get the new website with tools for teachers, we need to think of all of our partners on how we
share it with teachers and make it accessible with all that's coming at teachers right now and digital.
I'm excited about it, but I think if we want it to be used, we need to really be thoughtful about the rollout and that might be just something now you and your team need to think about and know that there are lots of educators in our state and at the county and district who would work with you to help roll this out.
Yes, well, thank you because we are planning to go to the regional assessment network group and they are our area leads for the assessment network.
So we're going to go to them next week with the information as well.
And they always give us input about how to roll out information.
So we'll be sure to gather that as well and have a plan for doing so.
All right.
Thanks.
Member Rucker and then Member Pagelina.
Thank you very much.
And now, first of all, I want to thank you for your very thorough and very comprehensive presentation about all the resources and the work that your division is doing.
And before I ask my questions, because my questions are predicated on a couple of on trying to make sure I get some clarification on some things I heard you say.
But before I say that, I do feel it inherent in my role on this panel and with my colleagues to make sure we talk about this issue about learning loss.
While this is not the first time that we have seen schools
that had to close.
We'll remember last year we lost a lot of schools because of the fire and time had to be taken away from students and from their schools because they had to close and there was learning loss.
But I think there's a gestalt in what we're trying to do right now with the statewide closure.
and this transition to distance learning, it's not just to try to restore the opportunity for students to continue their schooling, but also to figure out how the sum of all the parts of the work that goes in to making this distance learning plan work across the state.
The fact is the sum of each of the individual parts may actually be greater than the whole.
And this work that you're doing is an example of that.
And looking at starting with the tools for teachers I agree with Board Member Strauss that we not only need to make sure we think about how to make this available but how to unify the work that's being done in so many great venues by a lot of providers.
The examples I can give is I sat and listened in on several webinars now that Californians Together is doing to provide lessons and models for working with English learners.
As I listened to and saw the preview of the content on tools for teachers there's an opportunity to look at how to connect some of the work that was developed there to address the the instructional assessment blocks but also for the lessons and activities and the content that's given.
You know how do you scaffold that for English learners and where's the bridge and the bridging instruction that can be provided for that.
So we need to not only look at individually the work that's being done, but how we can create connections and collaborative work that's being done by a lot of organizations.
The second point I want to clarify because you did talk about how California purchased this.
I think a lot of stakeholders are confused how the professional development is being provided.
This is not a service or a product that districts must turn around and purchase.
This is a product and professional development
being provided to teachers free of charge.
Is that correct?
That is right.
It's part of our Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium membership.
And I think it's important for the state to remember, we put, California didn't purchase an assessment, they purchased an assessment system.
And so even though many folks remain concerned that the statewide assessment for accountability purposes
had to be suspended, the opportunity for teachers to use the assessment blocks and to use the formative assessments to embed them in the instruction that they're planning for distance learning still exists.
And the reason I'm bringing that up is the department put out an excellent guide on distance learning and on providing guidance for grading and distance learning and
supporting schools and students in implementing their plans.
Perhaps this is an opportunity to suggest amending that distance learning guidance to include an explanation to teachers on how to use the interim assessment options that are available to them for bridging and developing assessment lessons and assessment activities.
Because as a way of addressing this concern or perception about learning loss in doing this type of work and allowing teachers
the flexibility on how they pay attention to that could be helpful as well.
Does that make sense to you, Mel?
Yes, it does.
And it's about that coordination too, so that we don't do things in isolation.
So I appreciate your comments.
And we do hear how important it is to address the learning loss that all of our students are experiencing.
So I appreciate your comment overall.
And also, I wanted to, my staff did tell me that as for the tools for teachers, we are planning to do training
in July in California.
And we will have regional trainings.
We do have regional trainees, sorry, trainings, and then we do have trainers as well who are going to provide the trainings in late July.
They will be virtual trainings.
And we are reaching out to the system of support liaisons at all the county offices of education so that they could also support us in this rollout effort.
You read my mind because that was something I was going to ask you how you were going to do the rollout and what the contacts will be.
So the last comment that I will make on that point is I recall and many of my colleagues on the board will recall that when the state made the effort to roll out the digital library, the major impediment was a lack of understanding by the leadership and the local LEAs about who should have access
to that content.
I want to make sure I understood and heard you clearly that this content is being made available to every California educator who has a district email.
Is that correct?
Yes, that is correct.
So it doesn't matter if you're not one of the teachers in the grade or subject taught.
So it doesn't matter if you don't teach grades 3 through 8 or 11 in English Language Arts and Math, as long as you have
a district email, you have access to this content.
That's right.
And you can also go in and self-register.
Let's say if you're an instructional aid helping with English learners, you can even go and self-register if your LEA coordinator may not have included you in a teacher's list to submit as a whole.
We do have the option for anyone with a LEA email to self-register.
Well I'm sure my colleagues on the board have received a lot of emails or phone calls from California teachers because I personally have.
I get while I'm sitting here my phone keeps ringing and I'm getting calls from a lot of California teachers about what's going on with their digital learning.
I really want I really want to encourage your division to make sure that when you post this information it's made clear that all California teachers have access to this and to encourage LEAs to make sure that that access
is provided specifically by making sure they have an email because I personally plan to for all the webinars I keep being invited to to sit in and listen on.
I personally plan to share this information you gave to us today.
And I'm going to ask you to make sure your your slide show that you used for your presentation is made available to us because I would really like to distribute that to a lot of the districts who have asked me to listen in on their webinars.
when they're doing training.
I would really like to share this content.
OK.
The tools for teachers demonstration.
Is that what you want.
Yes.
Just this.
Right.
OK.
Just give me the slideshow.
I'll figure it I'll figure out how to use it.
Districts keep you know I get emails inviting me to sit in on webinars and listen from a lot of superintendents ask me to listen to the work they're doing and implementing their distance learning plans.
And I've spent a lot of time doing that and some of the work that you've created answered a lot of the questions
that they were raising with their staff about what kind of content and what kind of work can be their priority and what their first steps can be.
So, it would be nice to be able, since they invited me for some purpose, to be able to offer them something.
So, I'm very excited to see this presentation.
Well, thank you.
I will go ahead and put in some links for you and I will share the presentation.
Thank you very much.
All the resources I shared, I'll add additional links in there for you.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond, for letting me have that time.
Well, this is important.
And there have been and will be a lot of questions about diagnostic assessment, how we can support the assessment process.
And I know we've had some conversations about doing guidance specifically on that set of assessment questions for the fall, for whenever it is that teachers will be starting up again in the next
round of education, we're kind of getting out of the modality of thinking of the school year in the way that we have in the past.
But that's why this becomes so important.
So I'm glad you raised it.
And I think this is something that we should take up, maybe not just amending the old guidance, but, you know, creating guidance around this question.
I want to move to Member McGillivan, and then I have Member Burr waiting.
And Linda, we do have a public comment on this, correct, Amy?
Oh, we do.
They actually hung up, so they did.
OK, so no, no public comment, I guess.
OK.
Call back.
Member Pagelidad.
Thank you.
So I want to say thank you for the clarification first off because it definitely was a question of mine about the training because I know how difficult it can be.
Distance learning has shown that transitioning into technology.
So thank you for that.
That definitely clarified.
And then my other concern or question was kind of related to what Board Member Rucker
mentioned about the interim assessment.
So I do appreciate that they're optional because right now we definitely need some flexibility.
I was just wondering the kind of support that teachers would have going into that because the students who might need that measurement the most or showing that progress are the ones who might be the hardest to reach.
So I just have a concern that you know
Those might be needed by the students who will have the most difficulty, you know, testing online and getting those resources.
So I just wanted to know what kind of help is being provided to those who want to give these interim assessments to see how their students are doing, but maybe can't or are having difficulties reaching those students.
Yes, so every local educational agency has a district-wide coordinator so we communicate through them and we also provide the directions for teachers as well as students and or parents to support students from home directly to those coordinators.
So it's a statewide approach to sharing the information out there and we did all that communication I think at the very earliest in early April.
So, it's only been out there for a few weeks but we certainly will be happy to reach out to those coordinators to provide more support or resources as we hear what is needed and you are correct that it is very challenging for the students who may need the most help who are also probably the hardest to reach.
So, hopefully with all of our other coordinated efforts of getting
Wi-Fi to families who may not have it, to the other partners that are making it available for students who have the need to be able to have those types of logistical access that is beyond just teaching and learning, just the right tools and the right platforms for them to access the learning that should be taking place.
So, you know, it's not an isolated issue.
but it is pervasive.
If they have a need in one thing it's in another as well.
So hopefully in all of our coordinated efforts we will be able to reach more of the students who have the highest need.
Thank you.
And I'm going to ask Patricia to unraise her hand so that next time you want to speak I'll see that you're raising it again.
and go to Member Burr.
Before I do that, though, did anybody call back in on public comment?
Just want to be sure we're not missing.
Not yet.
OK.
Member Burr, and then I think if there are no further comments, we'll go to a break shortly after this.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
So a couple of things.
Now, one, I want to reinforce many of the comments that Member Rucker made.
and encourage you to reach beyond assessment coordinators and even county coordinators.
Because to me, this Tools for Teachers, which is a wonderful evolution from the digital library, is a perfect example of how this is an assessment system.
Our prior directors, Deb Sigman and Michelle Center, were very good about talking about how these are tools for learning.
We have a tendency I think to fall back into this is about accountability.
This is about testing.
That's not what this is about.
And particularly in this very new era that we're in where people are teaching in very different ways.
They need these tools.
And I worry a little bit and I think I feel a number of Rutgers pain because it took us a long time to get the digital library rolled out in a way that was helpful to teachers.
And so I encourage you to sort of think outside the assessment box.
Don't just be thinking about the regional assessment coordinators or even as much as I love the system of support people even beyond that because you have to get to the teachers who are trying to provide these services to students.
And to Brenda's comments the students who need it most are the ones that we really have to be clear about.
And I'm just a little worried that
This was a transition to a new tool that looks fantastic that was developed in a time before the pandemic and and was developed in a time of this is the way classrooms are used.
So I number one now would like some assurance that and I know a lot of people have been talking about this already that these tools for teachers really are going to be incredibly helpful in a new model and not a classroom only model a one-to-one student teacher model
But in this what's going to be I think a hybrid model as we move forward.
So that's number one.
Number two I heard you say it's available to people who have district emails.
I worry about charters.
How are charter schools being included because we have lots of teachers and charters who could use these tools as well.
So thank you for the opportunity to comment.
If they are charter schools are local educational agencies so they're they're
their email accounts are in the database as well, so they will be able to use it.
We don't exclude anybody who is part of our public school system, including our public charters.
And yes, in terms of outreach, Sue, I wanna reassure that we are making a lot of efforts beyond just our coordinators.
We just went to our stakeholder groups last week.
We did a couple presentations to the various stakeholders that come to our meetings, including like California Teacher Association,
California Federation of Teachers, and a number of other, like California Science Teachers, and the association, and just to name a few, because I can't remember them off the top of my head, but they were there to look at the demonstration of the tools for teachers.
We did make it available to them as well, so they can share with their constituents.
We also have, oh, in terms of the different stakeholder groups, we also had the Association of California School Administrators representatives there, Advisory Commission on Special Education representative, the California Parent Teacher Association, California Bilingual Educators Association, Californians Together, the California County Superintendents Educational Services Association,
We have California Charter Schools Association, California School Boards Association, the California Science Teachers Association I mentioned, special education local SELPA plan area representative and the small school district association.
Those are our usual stakeholder groups that we share any new development and anything that we bring to the board with them as well.
Great.
Could you just clarify now whether or not the tools for teachers were developed just as part of the natural evolution of Smarter Balanced or they do specifically speak to a hybrid instructional model.
Well it's let me see.
I have it is really to help
I mean, it's from the assessment side, however, it is to support and supplement instruction.
So there's instructional resources as well as, however, it doesn't guide instruction in the way, sense that your curriculum and instruction components would.
It also has professional learning components to it so that teachers and peers could collaborate in group settings.
So it does, it is more, I don't know whether, I understand whether it's a hybrid of a sort, but it is really an instructional resource to help with the instructional support side, but I don't think
I am articulating or addressing your question appropriately.
I think the question was whether it was specifically developed for this blended distance learning model that we're in now.
And the answer is that it started long before.
Yes.
It started being developed long before that.
Yeah.
And I think the question about how it may fit into the blended distance learning model that we're currently engaged in might be one that Mao, you could
reflect on.
Yes, I mean, I'll definitely reflect on that because, Sue, with your comment about how when the digital library was rolled out, I think at that time it was not ready, right?
Some components were in there, but it wasn't ready.
We as a whole
in terms of education in California, was trying to move on to online testing.
So even at that time, any online resources were at its infancy in development.
So the Smarter Balance has intended to make something more useful for teachers in terms of helping
to replace the digital library, right, to have resources like that.
But really, we will take into account how we could build this in and how we could, we will review what we are doing and how we could make it fit into the process.
So, let me see.
I think that's great, thanks.
Okay, yeah, at this time, I could just reassure you that we will figure out how we could fit it into the process.
I think that's going to be happening with a lot of tools and a lot of resources as we evolve this new set of new normals over the coming year.
So thanks so much, Mel.
It was a great presentation.
Appreciate all of the good information.
Lots of exciting new things rolling out.
I think before we go to the next item, we'll take a little bit of a break.
It's 9.56 on my watch, we'll come back at 10.10, okay?
And two, which is the accountability item.
So, Cindy Kazanas is going to present this item.
And I'll let her share with you the,
recommendation.
And the CDE is requesting guidance on the work to expand the CCI with some new career measures.
So, Cindy, please take it away.
Thank you.
Thank you, President Lyndon Arlene Hammond.
Again, Cindy Kazanis, the Director of the Analysis, Measurement, and Accountability Reporting Division.
I'm happy to be here today.
And in keeping with what Mel started as a tradition, I wanted to thank my daughter's first grade teacher, Mr. Watson.
Since we've transitioned to online learning like many parents, it's juggling work,
Zoom calls, and then lessons, like how to add and how to divide and things like that.
And so I'm very empathetic and grateful for our teachers and those out there who are leading our students in this time of great alarm, I think, for many of us.
We left last time's board meeting March board meeting thinking that we had a fantastic work plan to move forward with this year.
What you're going to see today is some abbreviations to that work plan based on the coronavirus and the impediments that we are facing with not being able to have our students take our assessments and attend school as they normally would.
And so you're going to hear a little bit about that today.
I want to assure you that we are hearing from districts, they are in school, they are reporting data.
they are doing what they need to do to make sure that students are being served and that we're able to measure appropriate student outcomes in this time.
Finally, while I'm here today presenting, there is one member of my staff here in the room, Jenny Singh, there are a multitude of others that helped put this item together and I can tell you working remotely it takes twice as long to do things and so we are adjusting to that and I wanted to thank them for their work to get this item prepared.
So we have a couple of attachments we're going to walk through.
We're going to definitely focus a lot today on our updated work plan and ask you for guidance around that.
I'm going to talk to you a little bit about attachment two in just a minute and then provide you an update on our continuing development or work around the college career indicator and then close out with our outreach activities.
We do have one appendix that is in the item.
We realize that there is another appendix that we referenced that was neglected to be put in the item, so we'll make sure that that goes in for further reference, and we'll walk you through components of that.
So with that I wanted to put forward a revised item recommendation.
We realized after hearing from members of the stakeholder community that there wasn't enough information for part of our action and so this is the revised action that we are recommending which asks the State Board of Education to provide guidance on our updated work plan as needed and provide guidance on work to expand the college career indicator with new career measures.
The original item included a mechanism to actually ask you to take action on our new color schemes for the 5 by 5 grids for the college career indicator.
and the chronic absenteeism indicator and the graduation rate indicator and the suspension rate indicator.
And while we have 30 charts and tables in our item, we neglected to put something in there related to the analysis of student group impact for these new color schemes.
So we will take that information back.
We will do that analysis and bring it back to you for action probably this fall.
So just wanted to
Let you know that we heard loud and clear that that information was really important for stakeholders to engage on this piece.
And by doing that, we'll actually be able to take it to the California Practitioners Advisory Group, which is going to meet in August.
So just wanted to make sure that I mentioned the reasons behind that.
So with that, excuse me.
I'm going to move over to the executive orders and the federal waivers that have impacted our work and what you'll see in the abbreviated or the revised work plan.
So similar to what Mal's already presented, I wanted to make sure that, again, we're all on the same page that back in March, again, the week after the board met, Governor Newsom suspended the California Assessment of Student Performance and Progress, the CAST, the English Language Proficiency Assessments for California, the LPAC for the current school year.
The U.S.
Department of Education, as you'll hear in item three, offered a streamlined waiver for the states to apply for to waive significant portions of the Every Student Succeeds Act related to assessments and accountability.
And on March 27th, the California Department of Education received approval for that waiver.
Under the federal waiver, the California Department of Education is not required to produce a dashboard in 2020.
This waiver, of course, only lends itself to requirements at the federal level.
It does not waive requirements at the state level.
In the next slide, I'm going to talk a little bit about the state requirements that still remain.
The Federal Waiver does apply also to reporting requirements including the State Accountability Report Card, the STARC, the Local Educational Agency Report Card, the LARC, and some data elements on the School Accountability Report Card or the SARC.
Additionally, the Federal Waiver
does not require the states to identify schools for comprehensive support and improvement or CSI or additional targeted support and improvement in 2020.
To support districts to understand the impact of the federal waiver, the California Department of Education hosted a webinar on April 21st in collaboration with our assessments division under Mao Vang
and Lindsay Tonatori, who runs our Title I division.
She has a new name that she's just announced, so you'll have to forgive me if I've already forgotten the new name, but the prior division was called the, again, it focuses on Title I work.
And so that webinar had over 3,000 participants.
It was very successful in getting the word out to the field on how the federal waiver, to our knowledge at that point in time,
affected much of our work.
So there still remains existing state law regarding the dashboard.
Specifically, the education code sections you see here require the CDE to produce a dashboard and to publicly report state and local indicator data.
Additionally, the sections that require the identification of districts and charter schools, again, the education code sections are listed here for differentiated assistance under local control and funding formula still remain in place.
The department and the state board
have made the administration aware as well as the California State Legislature of the complications of these existing state laws and again in the times that we are in and that we will not have data for certain indicators and the other indicators that we are collecting data on starting next week may be unreliable.
So I know that in your opening remarks, President Darling-Hammond mentioned the fact that the data collections are still continuing.
I'm proud to say that under the leadership of Jerry Winkler, our fall two data collection, which we extended out about a month and it closed at the end of April, had over 99% of our districts reporting information.
So we know that our districts are
Again, our working, our supporting students through things like data collection and reporting.
With that said, one of our more important data collections that comes in to talk about student outcomes begins this next Monday.
So that is our end of year collections.
These collections include information such as student discipline, student absence, which is our chronic absenteeism.
data, the four-year adjusted cohort data, and one-year graduation counts.
So while, again, we have a federal waiver that precludes us from producing a dashboard, we are really focused on using the data that is being collected starting next week to put information out on DataQuest and also to meet our federal and state reporting requirements because
Those have not been excluded or have not been waived from reporting out some of these, most of these measures.
Also, just in terms of student discipline, for the first time, we are collecting for all students information on restraints and seclusion.
So I just wanted to mention that.
I know it doesn't affect on the accountability side, but on the special education side, this is a very important collection for them.
I also wanted to mention that the department will do once the data collection closes, which we assume will be the end of August, although in past years we've had to extend that out upwards of a week to two weeks, we will begin processing that data.
This data is very complex and does take several months to process, dual process that is.
So I anticipate we'll be on the same schedule as prior years in terms of producing files for districts to preview and then producing this information again on DataQuest.
So preview and for a public release in November and then public release in December of this year.
So just wanted to make sure that folks are aware that this may not align with the new LCAP timeframe, but that, of course, as with all years, and when we talk
about data collection and data reporting.
This data is our local educational agencies data.
They own it and so they can definitely use the data they collect locally and they have in their student information systems to inform their local control and accountability plans.
So with that I'm going to switch over to our first attachment, which is our updated work plan.
You know, while there are some things that we need to shift away from this year to work on, there's actually a lot that we already had in our work plan that we can continue to work on, which you'll see.
in the next couple of slides.
So the first thing is we are committed to continuing our work and bringing forward to the board a student growth model for adoption this fall.
We are working very closely with our testing contractor, educational testing services to conduct simulations on the residual gain model.
and make technical adjustments to increase the model stability.
In fact, we have regular check-ins.
I even think that there's a weekly technical meeting that occurs.
We want to make sure that we have the technical components in place before we take this out to our growth model stakeholder group.
So we have taken this to our technical design group at their April meeting.
I wanted to remind those who may have forgotten that we spent actually all of last year working with WestEd who hosted a growth model stakeholder group and who helped really guide our work that we're doing today.
So we will reconvene that work group prior to your meeting in July to provide not only a progress update but to get feedback on where we've come over the last couple of months, where we're headed as well for this fall.
If you want additional information on that stakeholder work group that is included, there's actually a good summary that OSDED put together for us back in November of 2019.
There's an information memorandum.
So that is where I would direct you if you want to know about that growth model stakeholder group.
And of course, there's representatives on that, not only from the research community, but the advocacy group, advocacy community, educators, and we do have representatives from districts and county offices of education.
So moving, trying to move forward on our trajectory towards this, we will in June put forth an information memorandum for you all to review the work that's been done because this is a project that we've been working on since 2016.
Some would actually say that we started this back in 2010, but we won't go back that far So in 2016 began the work and so we'll give you really the history of it So you have the most recent chronology and you don't have to go back and look at various Info memorandums to get to to bring you up to speed on where we're at today, especially for our newer board members We will bring the methodology
forward to you, we'll actually bring forward a conversation in July to help prepare you for action whether it be in September and if you're not ready for that then we'll do that in November of this year.
We will be prepared again working with our testing or assessment contractor to produce a report on student level, rather to produce a student
growth model results from prior years for information purposes in December 2020.
The mechanism for that report and what it looks like is something that we're still continuing to work through.
And then shifting over to the college career indicator, this is another area that we've spent quite a bit of time on trying to build out new career measures.
And so some of the measures that we will bring forward to you in the fall, which are still on track, just wanted to reiterate this.
This is something that we can definitely do even in absence of the crisis that we're in right now.
So the career measures that we've been looking at in depth are the pre-apprenticeship program completion, state or federal jobs completion, transition program.
our classroom-based learning experiences and transition program, the work-based learning experiences.
And the collection of new measures that we are looking at for the 2021 school year are student internships, student-led enterprises, virtual or simulated work-based learning, armed services, vocational aptitude battery, ASVAB, which I think we discussed back in March.
So just to close out because I know that we're going to go through some of the College Career Indicator measures in my next attachment.
We'll pick up some of the details around those then.
And then finally, I just wanted to reiterate that the department is committed to continuing to look at the English Learner Progress Indicator.
And while we have a pause in testing for this year, there are about 300,000 assessments results that we understand are in the queue that these assessments were taken before the assessments were shut down in March.
And so the CDE will, I'll show you the next slide, we'll talk a little bit more about how we intend to use that data.
But for the current year and in 2021, we are committed to validating the current status cut scores, whether or not that means keeping them or bringing forward new information.
That definitely continues to be on our agenda.
for 2021 we will be able to create proposed change cut scores and we know that that will significantly affect districts colors and who may be eligible for differentiated assistance.
We will of course take this information to the LP work group who will actually be meeting in the next month or so.
the technical design group and other stakeholder groups and we'll bring forward the proposed cut scores again a year from now over a year from now when we have a full assessment of our students for this assessment to make sure we have colors for the 2021 dashboard.
And I just wanted to let you know that we are in conversations with the U.S.
Department of Education around this.
They are aware of these delays and are guiding us on this work as well.
So the 2020 results, the 300,000 assessments that we have, we think that we can do some really valuable analysis that will help guide our work for 2021 when we have that full set of assessments.
Again, we're expecting around at least 1 million to 1.2 million results.
This last year we had almost 900,000 matched results to use for this indicator.
So we plan to use that smaller group of assessment results to track overall validity and stability of the LP status over three years and look at trends over the three-year period for our LPAC summative assessments.
We want to make sure that we're analyzing it to see if there are changes in composition and size of English learners.
We know that the number of English learners in the population continues to decline.
So that has been consistent over the last several years of the population.
And then look specifically at our long-term English learner population and our reclassified fluent English proficient populations or our FEPs in California.
And we also want to make sure that we're using this information to look to see what should
put forward in terms of expectation of student increases for LP levels.
I think that's something that has been of concern in particular to the equity groups and so we will be looking at that information to help guide our work especially for the 2021 school year.
And then finally, one thing that we were able to add to our work plan as a result of being able to take some other things away that we weren't able to do this year is to work with the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence, or the CCE, to produce some graphic displays.
And so they've been receiving feedback, and even through our system of support here at the department, our level one and level two supports, just interest in having additional ways of slicing the data.
We'll partner with that entity as well as our internal staff to think about how we can again look at the data differently for a variety of audiences.
So the dashboard is not meeting everybody's needs and so how can we help to put out additional information again on the same data set but just in a different format that will help support districts to develop their improvement plans and help to I think support our communities to hold our districts accountable for
implementing those improvement plans.
And so we have been starting to ask the questions when we had our webinar in April.
We got several questions about what does a 2021 dashboard look like?
How do you look at status and how do you look at change?
And so we are starting to ask those questions not only of our technical design group but we'll also be sharing our thoughts and
providing you with the feedback we receive from our stakeholders as we approach this for the next school year.
But right now the current thinking is that status will be based on the most current year of data, so data from the 2021 school year.
And since there is no data that will be reported in the current school year for many of our indicators, the data from the 2019 dashboard will be used to determine change in performance levels.
And so that is the current thinking, and we will, of course, bring back a more thorough proposal as we vet this information out.
Okay so the other piece that we are looking for guidance from you on is around the well actually let me take that step back.
This is the attachment that we pulled and of course as I mentioned earlier due to the fact that we're still we need to conduct some further analysis at the student group level we'll bring this back to you this fall for consideration and approval.
So the third attachment that we're looking again for your guidance on and continued direction is related to the development of career measures for the college career indicator.
So as a reminder, measures in this indicator are primarily collected at the student level through our student level data system, the California Longitudinal Pupil Achievement Data System, or CALPADS.
College career activities completed through students for five years of high school are included when we determine the preparedness of a level of student.
We match this with some other data that we get from outside testing vendors such as the AP and IB.
But primarily our measures are definitely collected at the student level and provided to us from local educational agencies.
So in 2018-19, because of course it takes a little bit to ramp this up, right, we want to make sure that our student information service vendors, our SIS vendors, know what the collections are and so we sometimes have a couple year lead-ins until
until a measure is collected.
So back in 2018-19 the first collection was done for the following items.
So the completion of a pre-apprenticeship and when you see here why they're limited to maybe our dashboard alternative schools versus our non-dashboard alternative schools, that is due to direct
advisement of our policy work groups for not only our college career indicator, but also Alternative Schools Task Force.
And so those have been the policy groups that have really guided the conversation, but these measures have also come as a result of guidance, not only from you previously, obviously, because this was collected back in 2018-19, but also through groups like the California Petitions Advisory Group.
So the completion of the pre-apprenticeship is for DAS and our non-DAS schools.
Thank you, Malia.
And for the remaining measures, they are all limited to our DAS schools, the completion of state and federal, state or federal job program, the Workforce Readiness Certificate, and the completion of a Food Handler Certificate Program.
So while, again, it takes time to ramp up these measures, we then, once the measures are collected, we want to make sure that we do the proper analysis to make sure that they're valid and reliable to provide
to provide a recommendation to you for inclusion in the accountability system.
And so we have been meeting with again the College Career Indicator Workgroup as well as Alternative Schools Task Force meetings and those have been done remotely actually.
I believe part of them were remotely in February and then we just met with them actually this last week.
They have been very helpful in their recommendations and really thoroughness of vetting these measures out and and I This slide actually references appendix 2 so this is the appendix that does not exist in your item that we will make sure it gets into an addendum
It provides just some additional analysis of these measures that I think will be helpful to you as we bring these back to you for action later.
And so based on the feedback that we were, that these two groups provided, we have moved forward with some simulations, which we took to them this past week.
And so we'll provide that updated information to you in the near future, again, prior to you taking action on this.
So there was two of the measures that we'd collected data on that had been advised to us by not only work groups but the public on we should think about putting these in accountability system in which the stakeholders are now suggesting that they're not appropriate to include.
They are not implemented on a uniform basis at the district level and so they don't meet the level of rigor that the groups think that needs to be
there in order to include it into the College Career Indicator.
So that is the Workforce Readiness Certificate and then the Food Handler Certificate.
So we've actually come a long way, I think, on this measure in that we are now at a point where we've collected information, we found that the information is not uniform,
And so there may be some measures where we thought we were headed down a route and we could provide you more options under the career piece for the College Career Indicator where it may not be appropriate.
And so these are two measures in which that is what we are now hearing back from our stakeholder groups that it would not be appropriate to include due to lack of rigor.
And then on the special ed side, because the other concern is that our students with disabilities are not able to show that they are career ready under some of the traditional measures.
And so there are other things that we've been working with our special education division to collect.
And so our old student level data system for special education
which was the California special education management system information system or case miss which has now been retired they collected two measures in 2018-19 for students with disabilities or students rather with IEPs which was a completion of workability courses and work-based learning and the completion of a department rehabilitation work-based learning.
And so with this collection and actually lack of information from some of these measures from actually from LEAs, we actually have quite a bit of a, I think we have quite a bit of a challenge
out where we should head.
And so we are recommending in this item rather what we have found is that the workability in the Department of Rehabilitation Programs did not encompass the full range of work-based learning experiences provided by districts.
And so sometimes I think because these measures haven't really come to light and when you bring an accountability consideration into it, it provides much more of a high stakes
consideration, you find new things about this program that you didn't originally know when you started collecting the information.
So that's what we found out through the process of collecting the data, but also starting to talk about the data and the use of it in the accountability system.
And so we, in consultation with our special education division, are recommending that districts should be provided
flexibility to report, work-based learning opportunities, such as transitional services that they provide.
And so we're shifting our direction for these measures.
So beginning with the current year, so 19-20, the data definitions of the measures for the students with disability or students with an IEP were revised to be more inclusive, and they are currently, or this next, very shortly will be collected through CALPADS, or Student Level Data System.
So that is transition work-based learning experiences and transition classroom-based learning experiences.
So those are the two measures that we hope will, again, expand out the College Career Indicator for our students with IEPs.
So the next steps for our measures, measures for students without EPs, we are looking at classroom hours for the workability grant.
There was consideration about the scope of the hours and we will look at the data to recommend what are optimal hours because unlike in our
in our CTE field where there are certain set hours for showing that you've met completion, those don't exist in things that under the workability grant.
So we are using this information to help guide what would be considered
appropriate number of hours to get credit for our students with IEPs.
And help to inform our guidance to you, our recommendation to you on whether or not what would meet the prepared or approaching prepared levels for the indicator.
So we will put forward these recommendations to stakeholder groups and bring this back to you this fall in September.
And so this will also be able to be taken before the California Petitioners Advisory Group in August for feedback.
So with that, just to close out, this information was of outreach activities that we did in a month period of time.
As I mentioned, since then, we had a webinar that we had over 3,000 people participate in.
But during February and March, we did have a couple of
in-person presentations, and we had four virtual presentations.
So we are still active and available to the field.
We are participating in all the normal groups that we have been.
We've actually had new opportunities reached out to us to provide feedback.
We are doing some work around implementation of AB 1505, and so I think you'll see some more activity and different
outreach activities than you normally would in our next report.
So, with that, our revised recommendation is that the State Board of Education provide us with guidance on the updated work plan as needed and guidance on work to expand the CCI with the new career measures.
And I do have the public comment information available.
So, I'll turn it back to you, President Lindarly-Hammond.
Thank you.
Thanks for that very thorough briefing.
And as you can see, the public comment card is up.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment may do so by calling this number and following the instructions that are there.
While we're waiting for members of the public to call in, I want to ask Sue Burr and Eileen Strauss, who are our accountability liaisons, if they have any initial comments.
Then I'll ask board members if they have
very specific clarifying questions.
We'll get public comment and then we'll come back for a full discussion.
So Member Byrd do you want to start us off.
Sure.
Thank you President Darlingham and thank you to Cindy and all of her staff.
I think just as we expressed our appreciation in the last item these are challenging times and I appreciate their being innovative and their thought process about the work plan going forward.
on knowing that some a number of items have been placed on pause.
I really appreciate that.
The one thing I do want to emphasize and I really appreciate their attention to folks concern about the change in the recommended changes in the grids moving from 3 by 5 back to 5 by 5.
I think it is appropriate for us to take a pause and do some deep analysis
When I spoke to the staff I especially expressed my concern that we look at these changes through the lens of what does it mean for student outcomes and what does it mean for districts that would be otherwise placed in differentiated assistance.
I want to make sure that that's the way we talk about these changes.
What what will those changes mean both to students and to LEAs.
But other than that I appreciate all the work that you're doing and look forward to the future.
All right.
I could make comments following soon.
Yes.
Remember stress.
Well let me just again following up with member Burr's comments Cindy and her team have been so responsive and so thorough and I just so appreciate it and I I appreciate her comment about the effort it takes to work remotely I think most of us are discovering that it's
it's much longer, more intense, and that they got us to this point, I just so appreciate.
And also, I do think looking at the subgroup impact of the data before we make our modifications to stabilize, I think the need to have a
Measures that are stable and are not varied so much are important, but I think looking at the impact of subgroups will really give us more information before we make that recommendation.
So, I support the additional work and I look forward to seeing that coming back to us.
And I also understand that the LP work group, the English learner progress indicator, that group is coming together, I believe, the end of June.
And I think they're looking very much at the stakeholder input and how that impacts.
The whole process and all of our indicators have included stakeholder input, which actually has helped us get better.
And so I appreciate that.
And I look forward to hearing what the LP workgroup said.
And finally, I just think the graphic display will be helpful.
Like we have so much data, so much text, and the fact that you've added graphic displays to the work, I think will be a really nice tool for everybody.
So, and then the final comment I think is,
The student growth model we've been working on, I realize now it's been four years, but I think we're getting there and I look forward to more action this fall on the student growth model.
I think that that's an important piece for our accountability system.
I think many of our stakeholders have been sharing that support, but it sounds like it's going to go to CPAC and then back to us in the fall.
So again, as liaison, I think that's important to continue to build out our accountability system that uses that indicator.
Thank you.
Terrific.
If there are just clarifying comments, we'll take those before we get to public comment, and then we're going to try to get quickly to public comment.
I see a head went up and down.
So, we'll come back to you when we're in the discussion.
Don't want to miss the opportunity for public comment.
We wore out one of our commenters in an earlier session who gave up.
If there is public comment, we do want to hear it.
And Amy, do we have any public comment?
Yes, it looks like we do have some people signed up in the queue for public comment.
I would just like to remind everybody to make sure you press star six and then one to join the queue.
And I will open up the phone line now.
I think we want to ask whoever is going to speak to us through public comment to identify yourself.
with your name and any affiliation.
Go ahead caller.
Hi.
Thank you President Berlingham and board members.
This is Savannah Campbell and I'm calling on behalf of EdVoice.
We do really appreciate the board and CDE's response in pulling the 5 by 5 red stabilization methodology from item 2.
However we also remain concerned that if such a methodology is further pursued it would result in less transparency of achievement gaps and less assistance for LEAs.
With more than a year to consider a more equitable course of action for the 2021 dashboard, we do agree that there's plenty of time to consider every implication of this decision.
As member Eileen Strauss mentioned, we were particularly concerned that the item didn't provide any analysis of the methodology's impact on subgroup performance indicators.
We support the board's continued commitment to the implementation of a growth model as soon as feasible and the release of that historical growth data soon.
So thank you very much for your consideration.
All right.
Is there another comment?
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation.
This is Jessica Sacco with Children Now.
Good morning, board members, President Darling-Hammond.
I would like to first start out by really thanking the staff of the department for their incredible outreach during this crisis.
And they've really worked hard to make sure that stakeholders are well apprised of
all of the many moving parts both with federal federal accountability waivers as well as plans with the state and we really appreciate that outreach.
We're also pleased to see their plans laid out to continue progress continue making progress on development of the growth model and once again encourage that a robust communications plan be a part of that work moving forward.
We also support the issues that were outlined in the letter from the Equity Coalition.
Relative to the English learner progress indicator we are pleased to hear some of the updates that were presented today around opportunities to reflect on performance and progress as there are great concerns about that.
Thank you.
Good morning State Board of Education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Yes good morning.
This is Liz Guillen here for Public Advocates and some of us on the Equity Coalition that couldn't make it today.
Again we appreciate the department sharing its work plan.
One of the things we mentioned last meeting is that the work plan didn't include the establishment of the objective criteria for the teacher standard under Priority 1.
And we want to make sure that that isn't lost and so that we can implement last year's budget trailer bill.
I think the meeting a meeting is being planned but I'm not sure about that.
We're working on it.
I want to reaffirm comments that were made by Ed Boyce and Children Now.
I also want to repeat our concern that the CCI is being referred to as the college slash career indicator.
That's ambiguous and we think it departs from our last understanding that the intent is this for this to be a college and career indicator.
We appreciate all the hard work that staff has done in collecting and analyzing the additional measures.
And we agree that a food handling certificate.
Time.
Is not the expectation we want from our public schools.
For college and career preparation.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Good morning please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Martha Zaragoza Diaz for the California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
Good morning.
I am.
My comments are specific to the proposed revised accountability timeline for the LP on page 2 attachment 1.
We are opposed to putting off the review and validation of the LP cut scores until
2021.
We continue to be very concerned about the LP cut points for status which results in low levels of growth targets for our EL students.
We do not need to wait for three years of data to have a discussion on the cut points or to review the level of expectation we are setting for growth for our students.
California's LP cut score should expect a substantive percentage of students meeting the targets the board determines appropriate
We strongly recommend not to wait another year and to convene stakeholders in the fall of 2020 for the purpose of reviewing and making recommendations on LP's cut scores.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
This is LeAngela Reed on behalf of the Small School Districts Association.
Good morning.
Just want to thank the board and CDE staff for the thoughtful approach on the modification of the color scheme.
I think a little more time on this will be very helpful as you know for smalls the volatility has always been a key issue.
And I think looking at the student groups and having some of that information will be very very helpful.
So we look forward to working with staff to move that forward.
Thank you.
This concludes public comment for item 2.
OK, with the conclusion of public comment, we want to open this up to the board discussion and we may have some questions for you.
In fact, I'd like to just start off myself with two quick questions to clarify in relation to public comment for Cindy.
First, if you could clarify what is the plan for the indicators under the teacher standard under priority one and
Also, if you have any response to the questions about the LP growth score.
Sure so I'll take the first question around the teacher standard piece and so just so you're on the same page the budget trailer bill from this last year states that no later than January 31, 2021 the standards for local indicators which the department collects or otherwise has access to relevant and reliable school level data for all schools statewide shall to the extent practical
practicable be based on objective criteria which may include or not necessarily limited to the extent of any disparities across school sites within a school district or county office of education or performance relative to statewide data.
So I think that you heard today about the teacher
teacher data and I think that's the natural place to start because that is one of the local indicators that we've identified potentially with missed assignments that we'd be able to produce that information.
As I mentioned that data set just closed and so we are in the midst of extracting the data
from our student level data system and we will start working with that data soon.
Of course that data does not exist by itself at the department.
We have to match that data with data from the California Teacher Credentialing Commission to create what we consider missed assignments.
So the pieces about relevant and reliable school level data are pieces that we are continuing to work through.
We did have a call set for April, right the same day that the waiver was announced by the U.S.
Department of Education, so that call had to be rescheduled with the equity groups and in fact has not been rescheduled yet, but I know that
Public advocates were leading that that that charge and so we're really looking forward to connecting with them Remotely, of course in the next couple of weeks to talk through what this looks like in terms of the English on our progress indicator You know, we are looking forward to to feedback from you all about what we've proposed we have I think we think a very
solid plan to move forward on this indicator.
We've spent a lot of time thinking about these students.
I am, of course, a mother of two English learners.
I take this population very seriously.
We strive to serve students, especially our students with English, who are not proficient in the English language.
And so I look forward to feedback from you if there's things that you'd like us to shift in our current work plan on this but I think that we've laid out a process which we think we can move forward with that is valid, reliable and involves you know is based on real data and not based on a projected target of how many schools or districts should get into differentiated assistance or improvement.
due to this indicator.
That's not required under law.
And if the board wants us to take a different approach for this to get to certain numbers, we'd be happy to enter into that discussion.
So again, happy to turn that back to you, President Lindsay-Darling-Hammond, if you have further guidance around this measure.
Great.
Well, we may have other board members who want to speak to that.
Just before we leave the question of the teacher standard, in our ESSA Educator Equity Plan,
We had identified the fact that we would post data regularly, annually, beginning with this past year, on every category of credentialing of teachers.
You have the percentage of teachers who are on waivers, permits, intern credentials, as well as miss assignment.
So we're still kind of waiting to get that launched.
And I want to just be sure that when we come back to this, that we have all of those categories
as we discussed in a previous meeting and in our ESSA plan, in that plan to get that posted as soon as we can do that.
I know that the CTC and CDE datasets are talking to each other, which is a good thing.
And so hopefully we can get the results of that conversation into the mix pretty soon.
Let's see, we have Member Rucker's hand up, and if others want to speak to these issues, please go to the little box and raise your hand, okay?
Member Rucker?
Thank you very much.
My question to you is really about the concern about the LP and the development of the LP.
It seems the conversation and the particular objection that's being raised by stakeholders
is really a conversation separate from the work that's being addressed in the work plan.
So I just wanna pick at that for just a minute.
The work plan is very clear that the focus of the development of the floors and what will be recorded for accountability purposes is focusing on the development of that actual criteria.
And as I read and understand
what the stakeholders are saying or concerned about is that in the current work and in what is currently being reported, some of what has been recommended in the current development process will seem to have an outcome that for them is producing dubious results.
So I don't believe what I'm reading in the stakeholder letter is an objection to the process, but an objection to
what seems to be the outcomes from what is being recommended currently as the process is unfolding.
So I know that as part of your due diligence and as part of the work that you do with the workgroup and with the development of this particular criteria that I know you do data runs and I know you pay attention to how districts are identified how districts are pulled in.
and to make sure that there is some consistency in the way that the metrics are actually working.
So what I think I would ask you to do is I understand your concern about trying to forecast or trying to develop metrics based on what people think the outcome should look like.
I think this is going to be one of those times for us to be sensitive to what the stakeholders think is not being
clearly identified or identified in a quantitative way that is of matter to the stakeholders.
So, as you work on the metric, as you work on identifying how the metrics and the actual mathematics for the criteria will work, maybe pay attention to the development of the rationale for each of the elements in the criteria.
I think that might clearly address
the concerns that they are raising, because you all are really talking about two sides of the same coin.
And it's a relatively simple explanation from the experts that you're working with that I think will actually address and actually clarify
the concern that's being raised.
Cindy, do you think that makes sense?
I think it makes sense.
I'd just like to ask a clarifying question.
What I read in the letters, and maybe you're interpreting this differently, is that we need to go back and change the cut scores that were established for the 2019 dashboard.
That is exactly what they're asking for, yes.
So are you suggesting we produce a different dashboard for 2019 now that we've put it out and we have differentiated assistance, or are you suggesting that moving forward we look at the data set that we will have for this year, again it's a truncated data set, and in 2021 we'll have
a full data set, assuming that we're able to conduct this assessment to all of our students, and bring back that to you for action when we have the full data set.
We're in this gap here, and I'm just a little unclear as to what you're asking us to do.
I'm not sure how readjusting what was reported for 2019 will serve any purpose for purposes of monitoring and accountability.
I think that going forward,
in this gap year with the work you're doing now to figure out is there a way to address how what's being reported and whether or not there's any validity to raising or changing how the cut score would develop and how that was how that final what the recommendation is that you'll ultimately bring to us.
I think going forward there needs to be some attention paid to what the cut score is and whether or not it does need to be adjusted.
But I don't I'm not recommending or suggesting
if you need to go back and change the cut score that you set for the 2019 report.
But I do think we should pay attention to what happens with that cut score and the impact on what's identified going forward.
That is a very helpful clarification and I think the other piece that we miss because we only have status right now is that change will show a great deal of additional information.
It will shed light on districts that are doing
their part on an annual basis of moving our English learners through the systems, and those that are not will see those scores reflected in a color.
So I can't underscore, I hear Jenny and Jonathan Eisler in my ears telling me that color will make a big difference.
And so I know that it's very difficult to be patient, but I've taken your concerns down, Member Rucker, and I understand how you want us to proceed for the next year or so.
And then I have a question concerning the indicators for the technical education the 2 certificates.
Could you put that back up on the screen.
There was a slide you said that stakeholders objected to these 2 certificates because of the concerns about the rigor and
that can you, that it's not sufficiently rigorous for the CCI, the food handler certificate is not sufficiently rigorous for the CCI.
And the workforce spreading this certificate, there's concerns about how, what this measure actually reports or shows.
I looked at the information about who it is that actually earns these certificates.
So the fact of the matter is these certificates would include students in our CCI and it is the college and career indicator that normally would not be otherwise reflected in our database or in our data system for accountability.
So I want to understand what is the purpose what these certificates mean to employers and to the workforce for the students who attain them.
So when we were meeting, this is Jenny Singh, I'm the administrator of the Academic Accountability Unit.
We've been meeting with our CCI workgroup and with our Alternative Schools Task Force.
We originally wanted to collect the food handler certificate for our alternative schools.
But with the conversations that we've had with both workgroups, they felt that students who complete certain pathways, CTE pathways,
have the opportunity to earn the certificate.
And they indicated that it's only a two-hour course that's online, and most students, or most people, when they go and actually obtain a job at a restaurant or at some kind of food service, once they obtain the job, they're told to go and take the two-hour course and bring the certificate back before they start.
So they felt that this two-hour course really wasn't rigorous enough to be included.
For the workforce readiness certificate, this is something that our task force, our alternative schools task force wanted for DAS schools.
But we have very dedicated task force members and they have been going out and looking at the certificates from various districts.
and have noticed that they mean very different things at different districts.
Because it's not standardized, they mean different things, they just felt that that wasn't appropriate to include it in an accountability system right now.
Because when you include something in an accountability system, you want to make sure that it's the same throughout the state.
So it's not that they don't want to move forward with that at some other point in time, they just don't think this is the time for it, that we need to do more work in this area.
So thank you for sharing that information.
I appreciate that particular piece of detail.
I remain concerned, however, that we that by not including these certificates and I agree with the reasons that the stakeholders made or at least I understand the reasons the stakeholders raised and why these certificates are not appropriate at this time.
But it still remains important
that the that there is balance in the representation of students in our dashboard.
So not having an indicator and not having a metric that includes staff schools or that includes alternative schools remains a concern because it still means the college and career indicator is still primarily focused on regular education programs and on full academic programs and doesn't consider the diversity or variety of ways
that students need to be reflected.
This is now a validity to a lot of stakeholder concerns that the dashboard is still not transparent.
It is still not capturing the performance or engagement of all types of students in programs in the state.
So that means that work still needs to be going on.
We are working very closely with our alternative task force members and we do have some indicators in there that are specifically for DAS schools like the state and federal programs.
That is specifically for DAS schools.
Pre-apprenticeship really is more focused on DAS schools.
We actually got a complaint from the CCI work group that we shouldn't put pre-apprenticeships in right now because comprehensive schools have not really developed pre-apprenticeship programs yet.
And we said, we understand that, but we have a lot of DAS schools who've been doing this work for years.
So they get the biggest benefit from the pre-apprenticeship in regards to whether the students are gonna be prepared or approaching prepared.
And then of course we're adding in those transitional services for students with IEPs.
So we continue to do work in this area.
There's other things that our DAS schools want us to put in that they've been doing on a regular basis and those are the certificates, industry certificates.
We've been working very closely with our career and college division colleagues and we are hoping to collect that data next year as well.
So I wish we were a little further along, but we have been trying to work very hard to come up with indicators or measures that we think are really rigorous and that would be very helpful to students.
And I just wanted to add.
I appreciate.
Sorry, I just wanted to add that I think it would help if we were to provide you a matrix of what is currently in the mix.
Because right now we're sort of talking out of not having the full scope.
So that's what I just wanted to offer up.
They're going to give me another matrix of metrics right.
Okay the reason yeah and so Cindy you know where my mind is going on this because we Board Member Sun and I have a separate meeting tomorrow that's addressing some very peripheral but related concern this item concerning the Perkins 5 plan and what's actually reported about those students.
So this these data points are connected to what's in the matrix of metrics.
that's related to that plan.
I'm not going to dive in further into that because that's a separate board item but I want to make sure that not only are we being uniform and rigorous at what's developed but also diverse in a way that benefits what can be reported for accountability purposes for all of the programs that fall under the responsibility of this board.
So thank you very much for patiently listening to those questions.
I know that I have been impatient in the past with the development
of the CCI so that there is a balance of career indicators.
There are a lot of stakeholders for whom this is important not only for their program but for their students because the students need to see relevance in their programs but also see their work and the diligence that is happening in the development of these programs reflected in how the state values and reports on their work.
So thank you very much.
Thank you.
All right.
Member Cagillanat.
Hi, I just have one question because I was a little confused.
So, the English language progress indicator, has that truncated data set been determined to be accurate to make determinations that blood member record signify?
No, and I don't anticipate actually using it for any high-stakes accountability.
I think, if anything, it will help us for the 2021.
It will help us set us up nicely for the 2021 school year.
I also want to share that we actually don't even have that data set yet.
So, this would be work that we'd be doing over the summer and the fall.
I'm not seeing any other hands for conversation on this.
This is not an item where we need emotion.
So, with that, I would like to move us on to item number to complete that before lunch.
We're.
going to need to be a little bit efficient to do that, but I think we can.
Item three is to request a request to ratify a waiver of assessment accountability and school identification and federal funding flexibility requirements pursuant to the Elementary and Secondary Education Act.
This item does have an addendum.
as board members are taking a look at it.
And I will allow Joseph Saenz of the CDE to brief us on both the proposed actions and on the background for those actions.
Joe?
Hi, good morning.
I'm not Joe, obviously.
I'm Julian Cuevas, the Director of Government Affairs.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond, state board members, colleagues, and to all those watching this historic board meeting safely at home.
I'd like to take the moment and have the privilege of introducing
One of our newest members to the government affairs team, which is our federal policy liaison Joseph signs Joe brings analytical and policy experience stemming from his time with the California Department of Justice and the California Department of Health Care Services.
On the personal front, Joe's wife, Leanne, is a dedicated first grade teacher, and their daughter, Amelia, just turned three recently.
I'd like to also add, just in the last few months I've gotten the chance to know Joe, not only is he smart and intuitive, he's just an all around great guy.
And so, without further ado, I'd like to invite Joe to come up and present the next item on behalf of the Department of Education.
Thank you very much Julian for the introduction and thank you State Board staff for allowing me the opportunity to present to you today.
I just would like to give a big thank you to the State Board, its staff, and the CDE staff who's helped me through this waiver process.
It's been a lot of late night emails, late night texts, texts from me saying this might be a dumb question but so I just wanted to say I appreciate it.
In the spirit of efficiency and getting everybody to lunch, I will start presenting.
So I'm presenting item three, the request to ratify a waiver of assessment accountability and school identification and federal funding flexibility requirements pursuant to the Elementary and Secondary Education Act.
So to start off, the CDE recommends that the State Board of Education ratify the assessment and accountability waiver for the 2019-2020 school year of the following sections under ESEA section 8401B.
Those would be assessment requirements in section 1111B2, accountability and school
Identification requirements in sections 1111C4 and 1111D2C through D. And also reporting requirements related to assessments and accountability in section 1111H.
This would be also to recommend that the state board of education ratify the federal funding flexibility waiver of the following provisions for the 2019-2020 school year.
Those would be section 1127B which is title one part A of the ESEA.
so that the CDE may waive more than once every three years, if necessary, the 15% carryover limitation in ESCA section 1127AAA for fiscal year 2019 Title I Part A funds, section 421B of the
for the period of availability of fiscal year 2018 funds for programs in which the CDE participates under its approved consolidated state plan.
This would be until September 30th, 2021.
And the also section 4106D of Title IV Part A related to local educational agency needs assessments for the 2019-2020 school year.
Title IV Part A with respect to content area spending requirements for federal years 2018 and 2019 Title IV Part A funds.
and Title IV Part A of the ESEA with respect to the spending limitation for technology infrastructure, as well as the definition of professional development for activities funded under the 2019-2020 school year.
That's a lot which I will explain in straightforward terms in this presentation.
So just to give you a little bit of background on these flexibilities, due to the coronavirus outbreak in the United States, President Trump declared a national emergency on March 13, 2020.
Later on, Governor Newsom issued a statewide shelter-in-place on March 19, 2020.
In response to the coronavirus, the Congress passed the CARES Act, known
longer name the Coronavirus Aid Relief and Economic Security Act on March 27, 2020.
So as many of you know, this provided relief funding to K-12 education as well as institutions of higher education.
But why we're here today is the provision that it allows the Secretary of Education to waive any statutory or regulatory requirement such as those relating to assessments, accountability, allocation of funds and reporting through a streamlined waiver process.
So first I'm going to dive into the assessment and accountability waiver.
So on March 18th, Governor Newsom issued an executive order announcing California's intent to pursue a federal waiver of testing requirements.
On March 20th, the U.S.
Department of Education Secretary Betsy DeVos invited states to request a streamlined assessment and accountability waiver.
So under this waiver, states would not need to administer statewide assessments, make annual accountability determinations, identify schools for support and improvement, or provide data on a state and local report cards for assessment and accountability information.
On March 26, the assessment and accountability waiver was submitted jointly by the State Superintendent of Public Instruction, Tony Thurmond, and California State Board of Education President, Linda Darling Hammond.
The CDE also held concurrent public comment period while the waiver was submitted, which was open through April 15, 2020.
On March 27, 2020, the U.S.
Department of Education provided formal approval for the waiver.
And just to note, all 50 states have applied for and received approval for this waiver as well.
So this waiver weighs assessment requirements which covers the requirements to administer all required assessments in the school year 2019-2020.
It weighs the accountability and school identification requirements.
So these are the requirements for differentiating all public schools and the requirements to identify schools for comprehensive and targeted support and improvement and additional to targeted support and improvement based on data from the 2019-2020 school year.
And it also weighs reporting requirements related to assessments and accountability.
So we did receive public comment on this waiver.
They were submitted from schools, school districts, county offices of education, organizations, and parents.
We only received one opposing comment.
We received support from the Local Control Funding Formula Equity Coalition.
And so that's what I have for the assessment and accountability waiver.
And again, our recommendation is that the state board ratify this waiver.
And now I will go into the federal funding flexibility waiver.
So on April 3, 2020, the U.S.
Department of Education invited states to request a waiver which would allow for additional flexibilities of federal funds for the 2019-2020 school year pursuant to the CARES Act.
So one of the first big pieces of this waiver is that state education agencies would be able to approve LEAs to carry over more than 15% of its Title I Part A funds.
It also weighs the limitation of carryover more than once every three years.
It also extends the period of availability of 2018 funds.
So these first two flexibilities give LEAs more time to address the needs of their students during this pandemic.
but they do not waive allowable activities for the specific titles that they impact.
So I just wanted to note that.
The flexibility as you see in the third point for Title IV Part A funds actually do permit LEAs to use these funds to best meet its needs without regard to content area spending requirements, spending limits on technology infrastructure, or completing a needs assessment.
So for instance, one area it can impact is the digital divide.
LEAs could use these funds to purchase devices, equipment, and software applications to address readiness shortfalls.
And then the fourth point below, this waiver waives the definition of professional development.
So this can allow time-sensitive professional development for educators to provide effective distance learning.
So on April 10th, this waiver was submitted by the State Superintendent of Public Instruction, Tony Thurmond, and California State Board of Education President, Linda Darling-Hammond.
Again, this was a concurrent public comment period that was open through May 1st, 2020.
Again, these public comment is being used to inform CDE on implementation.
On April 22nd, 2020, the U.S.
Department of Education provided formal approval for the waiver.
And so like I spoke to earlier before, it allows the waiving of Title I Part A funds for more than once every three years if necessary and more than the 15% carryover limitation, waives Section 421B of the GEPA to extend the period of availability of 2018 funds for programs, and waives Title IV Part A of the ESEA related to local education agency needs assessments for the 2019-2020 school year.
Also, it waives Title IV Part A of the ESEA with respect to content area spending requirements and with respect to spending limitation for technology infrastructure for fiscal years 2018 and 2019.
And lastly, again, it waives the definition of professional development for activities funded under the 2019-2020 school year.
And as this slide says, there were no public comments received, but due to the timelines we had between the state board meeting and when these slides were due, we actually did receive three public comments, which I will go through verbally.
There was a letter from the Riverside County Office of Education that was in support of the waiver.
Also, there was a letter from the LCFF equity coalition that stated the coalition was appreciative of the waiver for carryover of title funds with the recommendation that the CDE remind LEAs that Title I funds are subject to a supplement, not supplant rule.
in the Every Student Succeeds Act.
And our webinar that was held on this was on April 23rd, and it was the first of many to come that will reiterate this.
So we have noted this in our webinars and in our communications with the field.
Also, the LCFF equity coalition letter recommended the CDE report to the state board the amount of Title I funding that LEAs are not spending and carrying over into the next year, especially given the budget outlook for the future.
The letter also showed appreciation that the waiver for the definition of professional development allows LEAs to conduct time-sensitive one-time or standalone professional development.
However, the letter recommends reinforcing that the majority of professional development should still meet the current definition.
The letter also recommended the CDE provide guidance for LEAs for how they approach professional learning using the different elements of the WAVE definition.
And lastly, there was a letter from Teach Plus that expressed concern for waiving the official definition of professional development.
The Teach Plus letter recommended that the state board direct the CDE to provide concrete recommendations for how LEAs approach professional development during this time.
So in closing, the CDE recommends that the SBE ratify the federal funding flexibility waiver for the following provisions for the 2019-2020 school year under ESEAA section 8401B.
and this would be for Title I Part A funding waiving the 15% carryover limitation and the more than once every three years limitation.
Also Section 421B of the GEPA to extend the period of availability of fiscal year 2018 funds.
And Title IV Part A of the ESEA related to LEA needs assessments for the 2019-2020 school year.
recommending that they ratify the waiving of Title IV Part A of the ESEA with respect to content area spending requirements and with respect to spending limitation on technology infrastructure, as well as the definition of professional development.
Sending back to you for questions.
Great.
Thank you.
We're going to be opening the phone line for public comment and I want to see if you could put that slide back up there that shows the public comment phone number.
should probably there you go.
So members of the public you know wishing to provide comment can do so by calling this number and entering the access code and while we're waiting for members of the public to call in I want to ask Sue Burr and Eileen Strauss as our accountability liaisons if they have some initial comments.
Then I'll go to any clarifying questions from the board.
We'll then take public comment and then come back to for discussion.
So member Burr do you want to start us off with
some framing.
I would just say express my appreciation to the department staff and the board staff for their action.
They sprung into action as did you and Superintendent Thurmond when we really needed to take action quickly.
I appreciate the thorough presentation.
I think the waivers have been laid out very clearly and I would recommend that we adopt the recommendations.
Happy to make that motion when you're ready.
Okay.
And Member Strauss.
So, again, I'll support what Member Burr said.
I think right now, flexibility is welcomed and essential.
And I think not knowing what the budget outcome is, but we know it's a dismal outlook.
We need the flexibility.
I think we probably should hear going forward how this plays out as the situation continues to develop.
But I would totally support this.
I would second the motion and thank staff
for responding so quickly to get this process for us.
Terrific.
Are there any brief clarifying questions?
Okay, seeing none, we'll go to public comment if there is some.
Yes, it looks like we have five people so far signed up for public comment, so I will open up the phone line now.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Hi good morning.
This is Andrea Ball here on behalf of the Central Valley Education Coalition and the California Association of Suburban School Districts to support the recommendation to ratify the waivers.
And I really want to thank the staff the state board the state superintendent for your championing this flexibility and also for your advocacy to federal legislators and policymakers
I know the state superintendent was in D.C.
was advocating with our representatives in D.C.
and Board President Darling-Hammond wanted to thank you for your commentary on May 4th where you laid out what the challenges are and the plans we need to reopen schools and recognize that we need to get the CARES Act funding that's been allocated out quickly to schools to meet needs and also
to continue to advocate for additional federal support for education.
So thank you very much.
Really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Yes good morning.
This is Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
We appreciate the presentation very much.
Welcome to Mr. Sines to joining the department.
And appreciate that our comments have been taken into consideration as far as reminding LEAs that Title I is still subject to supplement not supplant rules.
We do want to underscore that now more than ever we think that parents and the public need to know how much Title I funds are being carried over.
And so we recommend that this information be collected and presented for transparency purposes.
And in terms of the professional development definition, while we agree with the flexibility and the need to use professional development in a responsive way, we want to reinforce that the rest of the definition around that it be sustained, intensive, collaborative, job-embedded and data-driven really should not be ignored.
So we hope that that will be included.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Hi this is Leticia Garcia on behalf of Riverside County Superintendent of Schools Dr. Judy White.
Just wanted to take this opportunity to thank Board President Hammond and Superintendent Thurmond for your leadership during this crisis and all of your support for for all the schools.
And also Riverside County has been greatly impacted by this pandemic having the second highest number of cases in the state.
So your leadership in seeking the federal waivers came at a critical time while our districts were were undergoing their planning process for distance learning and implementation.
These federal waivers will provide the much-needed relief that they need at the local level to meet their very specific needs.
and also to work to address the inequities in student access and outcomes.
So we thank you again for your strong leadership and advocacy and your continued support as we get through this crisis and again in support of ratifying the waivers.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
My name is Sheila Whitley.
and I represent the California Teachers Association.
CTA appreciates the hard work of the CDE and SBE leadership and staff to submit and shepherd through the approval process of our state's federal waivers of assessment accountability and school identification and the federal funding flexibility requirements during these trying times.
CTA
CTA called for a suspension of the statewide testing because on any given day and under the best of circumstances test scores alone fail to tell us how a child is doing and where they need improvement.
That would be even more certain for students in the wake of the COVID-19 pandemic.
In addition to the physical health of Californians the health of our state's economy has been harmed by the COVID-19 pandemic.
And the Federal CARES Act will allow the state and LEAs to devote more of their federal resources to support distance learning for students and for professional development for teachers who are teaching remotely.
We understand that this waiver will not fix any of the current budgetary issues but will at the very least provide some help.
CTA supports the CDE recommendation that the SBC ratify the assessment and accountability waiver and federal funding flexibility waiver for the
2019-20 school year.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing the California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
We understand the need for LEA flexibility regarding the use of federal funds during this crisis.
However it is
recommended that LEAs be reminded and informed that Title I funds, whenever used, are subject to the supplement, not supplant, rule pursuant to ESSA.
The U.S.
Department of Education did not waive this rule.
It is very important that students in Title I schools receive state and local funds they would otherwise be entitled to if their schools were not receiving Title I assistance.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Hi yes this is Elizabeth Esquivel with the California Association of School Business Officials.
Also wanting to thank you for all the work that you'll have been doing during this crisis.
Our local schools across the state are working hard to keep instruction moving forward.
Every dollar of discretionary funding that can be passed through to local school agencies from the federal financial assistance should be done as quickly as possible.
We urge you to avoid creating state administered programs that will delay the ability of local schools to access resources that are needed immediately and instead to allocate the funds on a formula basis for LEAs to use as they determine what is necessary to meet the needs of their students and communities.
We also request that the state provide a minimum funding level for small school districts to recognize their scope and size.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
That concludes public comment for item 3.
Very good.
So we'll be able to take conversation from the board.
I'd like to just kick us off by noting that I appreciate the comments from several of the members of the public about the importance of continuing to have strong approaches to professional development.
And I'm very attached to the language in the federal law about the
that I think one of the commenters just quoted.
It came from a research review that my organization did a couple of years ago.
And I think the reason that the
The waiver of that definition is on the table is because there is a need for certain kinds of very specific professional development right now.
Like, how do you run a Zoom classroom?
What do you do at Google Hangout?
You know, and things like that that are not going to necessarily have that
long duration and sustained collaboration around those particular themes.
So we recognize that this is a unique time and that kind of professional development is also needed.
And it's, I think, a useful
reminder that our interactions with districts and reminders to districts about good professional development features continue.
But it seems appropriate in this moment to seek the waiver of all of those those components.
And so I certainly endorse the request from the department for that.
And let me see who has raised a hand here.
Anybody want to engage in any discussion about this waiver?
If you're hungry, we could just go to a vote, but I don't want to cut off discussion.
Yes, Member Sun.
And then Member Rucker.
Oh, sorry.
I need to turn my camera back on.
Sorry.
I'm using my iPad, so it's a little bit touchy.
Yeah, I'm hearing all the comments and I didn't make a lot of comments on our last three items, but I think this is just, I wanna just make a general comment that encompasses the items that we've discussed.
As I've listened to the questions and the public comments and the concerns, we know that our schema of how we deliver instruction curriculum assessment has completely changed over these last four, five weeks.
And I was feeling a lot of anxiety because I felt, wow, we're starting to dismantle a lot of the things that we've worked so hard over the last eight years to put in place.
And so I absolutely support the practical need for flexibility at this point in time.
And as we are working through these challenges, I want to ensure that we move forward with integrity
on what we had initially launched this, our accountability system, our assessment system on.
And I do have some anxiety around the LPAC, the suspension, postponement of the LPAC and what it would do for LPI.
We had so much momentum going on that.
And so as we move forward, I think even if we don't have some of these structures that we've designed in place,
We need to make sure that we are all working together moving forward with integrity as we work with flexibility.
And I think that's just generally what I say.
I don't have anything specific in that.
But that is a concern as we move forward.
I take your point.
Member Rucker and then Member Patil-Bronson.
Thank you.
I think that
The concerns that are being raised by stakeholders, we need to recognize that these would be concerns even when we have the regular education program going on.
What has happened with distance learning is it has put a laser focus on the inequities and the concerns we already have about equity and access for students that are the target and the intent to be the beneficiaries
of the funding that's being provided to us through ESSA and other federal funds.
And the fact that these funds exist already is supposed to point out the fact that programs need to do more to provide better and improved services and access for the students.
And so, yes, we are in unique times, not just unique because we have this statewide health crisis, but unique because this statewide health crisis and the
required closure of schools has increased the focus on what already is not happening to provide the service and support to the students.
And I agree with Board Member Sun, we have created a lot of momentum in the attention that has been given to our efforts and initiatives that have been created to address these concerns and these programs.
And I think that
flexibility while the stakeholders are concerned that something will simply stop or cease.
The flexibility is important for some very specific and practical reasons.
Think about the first days of school.
Teachers spend a lot of time making connection to and actually finding and meeting and learning about their students that create community.
For a lot of people who have the mental model that distance learning is somehow
an electronic substitute teacher, teachers need to spend time finding their students again, making connections to their students again, finding out that they are okay and figuring out how to create that important student-to-teacher and teacher-to-student and lesson-to-student interaction that students rely on that's part of the gestalt of what creates the climate and culture of schooling and what they do to learn.
So the types of training, the types of professional learning, so just the time to teach teachers how to turn on a Zoom camera and to make sure they understand what's in the background of their camera and all of those things, those are important one-shot professional learning activities that we didn't have to consider before that are very important to give districts the opportunity to provide that support
two teachers and also two students.
There's also support that's being provided to parents who this being the week of teacher appreciation, parents are gaining a new appreciation for what teachers do with their children all day in those classrooms because now parents and the home environment have become part of the classroom environment.
So the training and the intent behind these waivers
It's not to stop the momentum of good work that should be paid to high quality professional development.
The intention really needs to be purposely stated to create the quality in the transition that will ensure the kinds of learning loss that people are concerned about does not occur or have the sustained effect or impact.
I think it's intended to be more compensatory than anything.
Now that said,
The language of the waiver does very carefully craft the language about not needing to identify new schools for intervention or support.
The language of the recommendation from staff does not actually consider what is our ongoing responsibility, schools that have already been identified for some type of comprehensive or targeted support.
So I think that stakeholders probably want to know that there is a concomitant responsibility for the board and the department and all those agencies that are part of our support network.
Those schools will continue receiving that support as well.
And waiving a lot the requirements for accountability and identifying schools does not change the work that is continuing and is ongoing with the schools we already have that relationship with.
Thank you for clarifying that that is indeed the case and something that it's important for people to know.
I'm going to ask Member Rucker and Member Sun to take your hands down in the little box there and call on Member Patil-Branson.
I'll keep it short because I just want to actually co-sign to what Board Member Ting and Rucker had offered
I think this idea is very clear that we obviously need additional flexibility and waivers in this particular moment, but it also doesn't give us license to take our foot off the gas for all of the other equity work that has been ongoing, that it will be continuing.
And I think for all of our stakeholders who are watching this closely, as is appropriate, that
COVID-19 didn't create all of these inequities and inequalities that our kids are facing.
It has only just made it just capably obvious how much, how precarious so many of our learning situations have been across the state.
And so just wanting to make sure that we're all clearly articulating that this work has to continue and the flexibility doesn't take away from that.
Okay.
I think that's all of the identified discussion.
So I wonder if we could come back to Member Burr who suggested she would be prepared to make a motion.
Yes I would I would like to move the department's recommendation and as it's outlined in our agenda item it's two parts to ratify the assessment and accountability waiver for the 19-20 school year
and to ratify the federal funding flexibility waiver for the 19-20 school year.
Second?
I'll second.
Okay, we have a lot of seconds.
I'm sure somebody who's taking those will figure that out.
Seeing that we have a motion and a second, I think we're going to need to take a roll call vote.
Karen, will you manage the roll call?
Yes, and I think I heard the second was Eileen or was it Matt?
You can go with Eileen, that's fine.
Okay, so Eileen did the second, just forgive me.
It was a photo finish, I think we have to rerun the tape.
Okay, member Burr?
Aye.
Member Darling-Hammond?
Member Navo?
Aye.
Member Pangilini?
Member Patio-Bronson?
Aye.
Member Rucker?
Member Strauss?
Aye.
And Member Sun?
Motion passes.
Very good.
I think this would be a good moment at which to pause for lunch so that we don't end up in a longer item than we thought we would at this moment.
We can take about 30 minutes.
It's about 1146 on my watch.
So around 1216, we will see you back here.
All right, turn off your cameras and your audio.
We don't need to hear whatever you're saying to your family members.
I think I'm waiting for someone to tell us that we're live.
Yes, we're checking to make sure.
OK.
Just wanted to be sure that.
OK, we're live and I will I will do the roll call so we know we have a quorum.
OK.
Member Sung.
You're on mute.
Strauss.
Here.
Rucker.
Petio Bronson.
Here.
Pangilini.
Navo.
Here.
Darling-Hammond.
Burr.
Here.
We have a quorum.
All right.
Very good.
Welcome back.
We're going to proceed with item number four, which is the math framework item.
And I'll let Shanine Coates from the CDE present both the recommendation and the item itself.
Shanine, take it away.
Thank you so much.
Good afternoon, board members.
I'm Shanine Coates, the Director of the Curriculum Frameworks and Instructional Resources Division.
I'd like to, in honor of Teacher Appreciation Week,
I just start by thanking Ms.
Maiden, Mrs. Lee, and Mrs. Cheney.
They are my daughter's first, third, and fifth grade teachers.
So thank you to them.
In light that this is a math framework, I would also like to thank Mrs. Dilley, my 10th grade math teacher.
So today we will discuss the recommendations to revise the mathematics timeline in light of COVID-19.
And the recommendation is as follows.
The California Department of Education recommends that the State Board of Education take the following action.
Approve the revised timeline for the 2021 revision of the mathematics framework for California public schools, kindergarten through grade 12.
This is a visual representation of the framework development process.
You may have recognized it from a prior State Board of Education meeting.
I will lead off with it here in order to recap the process for the development of a curriculum framework.
As you might recall, we started with our process in August of 2019 with the convening of several focus group meetings.
When I came before you in January of this year, we were at the second bullet, the red bullet there, and you appointed the Curriculum Framework and Evaluation Criteria Committee members, as well as approved the guidelines for the revision of the Mathematics Framework.
Shortly after, at the end of February, the Maths CFCC held its first meeting.
As we were preparing for the second MATH CFCC meeting, which was to have taken place at the end of March, we were faced with COVID-19 and counties and employers began issuing freezes on travel and local stay-at-home orders.
Subsequently, the statewide shelter-in-place order was released.
Here you can see the proposed changes to the timeline side by side.
As I stated prior, the first meeting of the CFCC was held in February of this year.
We postponed the March, April, and May meetings to allow time to determine the best way to ensure virtual options for the MAF CFCC members as appropriate and to allow the CFCC members who are educators and who are responding to COVID in their local communities the option to do so.
In the proposed revised timeline, the original June and August meetings have remained and we have added three new meetings.
So instead of the six CFCC meetings, which were to take place February, March, April, May, June, and August,
We now will run the meetings through December 2020.
That is, we will have meetings February, June, August, September, November, and December as proposed.
It is worth noting that we have checked with every CFCC member, and 19 of the 20 have confirmed their availability on these three new proposed dates, and we are awaiting confirmation from the 20th member.
With regard to the meeting format of the remaining CFCC meetings, several members indicated their preference for the department to consider virtual participation options.
Finally, it is also worth noting that our writing team has confirmed their availability for the new meeting dates, as well as all of the revised timeline dates, which I will now discuss.
With the addition of the three new CFCC meeting dates in the fall of this year, the subsequent framework development milestones have been adjusted.
First, in the revised timeline, the IQC will review and approve the draft mathematics framework in January 2021, with the first of the two public comment periods now taking place between the months of February and April 2021.
Next, the IQC and the Mathematics Subject Committee will analyze the recommendations and edits received during the first public comment period at the May 2021 IQC meeting.
At the same May 2021 meeting, the IQC will also formally act to recommend the draft framework to the State Board of Education while simultaneously approving it for the second 60-day public comment period.
The second 60-day public comment period will now take place in the months of June and July 2021.
after which we have added a placeholder milestone for your consideration.
I would like to provide some context for this additional milestone.
This step is not a mandated requirement.
However, with recent frameworks, the SBE has requested that
the IQC meet again following the second 60-day field review to analyze and make recommendations on the second batch of public comments received.
It is within your discretion whether you would like to instruct the IQC to do so for the mathematics framework.
If so, we recommend that this meeting take place at the scheduled August 17, 2021 meeting of the IQC.
Finally, in the proposed new timeline, you would be receiving the draft revised mathematics framework for board action at your November 2021 meeting.
Therefore, I am here today to seek approval of the revised timeline for the 2021 revision of the mathematics framework for California public schools, kindergarten through grade 12.
I would be happy to answer any questions you may have at this time.
President Darling-Hammond.
All right.
Do we have any?
Well, first, I guess we should check to see if we want to hear from our liaison.
I know Member Rucker may have a few comments before we go to clarifying questions.
And we see we have a public comment right up there.
So Member Rucker, do you want to give us a framing comment?
Sure, thank you very much.
I think it is important to understand that delaying the three meetings is the best choice in light of everything that's going on and the impacts for COVID-19.
It allows the educators who are participating with us on this framework development, the space needed to respond to their local situations, but more importantly, it also allows the CDE, the opportunity,
determine the best virtual option to ensure that in the way that the framework committees work and deliberate together that we can ensure that the conversations that are needed to develop the framework could continue.
I'm happy to say I had the opportunity to attend the very first Mathematics Framework Curriculum Committee in February and I was able to witness not only what the robust discussion was
But how important it was for all of the folks who were on that committee to meet together in the whole room, but also as they did their breakouts, the flexibility they had for moving around and moving in and out with some fluidity in and among those different groups that they were meeting.
It's important that the discussion around those first two chapters happened because those two chapters were brand new chapters on data science and number sense.
And so I can't imagine what kind of work would have to happen for the department and for those folks on the framework if we were still in, if we had just gotten started and hadn't even had the opportunity for that very first meeting.
It's inevitable that the pandemic is going to continue to inform our work on the math framework committee.
I'm certain it's definitely going to change or inform the way some of the vignettes are written or developed.
the delivery of instruction.
And I am quite certain teachers have a greater understanding about what access to the curriculum most definitely means right now.
I also, I'm prepared at the time we make the move to the motion, I am prepared to make sure that when we adopt the revised timeline, that we do include the milestone meeting
We don't have to have the meeting if there is no public comment in the second public comment period of the MAP framework, but I'm quite sure it's going to occur.
I think we can probably be pretty confident about that.
Yeah.
Are there any brief clarifying questions before we go to public comment?
All right.
Do we have public comments?
It looks like we may have one person signed up or wanting to speak possibly but they are not in the queue yet.
So I just want to remind all callers to please press the star 6 button and then 1 to join the queue.
Well we'll give them some time.
I think I just saw Member Patio-Bronson's hand go up for a clarifying question.
So.
Thank you.
I just wanted to confirm with Board Member Rucker so it doesn't need to come back.
to the board if they decide to hold the fall meetings virtually in the event that things continue to evolve with COVID?
My request, my suggestion in making the motion to accept the timeline would be to include the milestone meeting, yes, so that we don't have to take additional board action.
I believe since that's the work we've done with the past two frameworks, it's probably a good idea just to go ahead and approve that meeting with this timeline.
Thank you.
And now do we have any public comment?
No, we do not.
It looks like they hung up.
Oh.
It's just like doing a call-in show, you know, like, you always say, well, call in, right?
We have our call-in number.
OK, so we can open it up for any further discussion.
Member Strauss?
Yes, I want to just follow up on the comments that member Rucker said this framework is so they were updated this framework is so ready necessary.
We've learned so much since this is the first framework we developed after the recession last time and we've gotten really even better at developing guidance and framework documents as each subsequent framework have been developed.
And I think while the delay is understandable, it is actually disappointing because we have people who've lived with our framework and know what we need to do to make it better.
So I just want to say this is the one we need to continue working on.
All of our frameworks are such important guidance documents now, particularly when people are teaching remotely and needing references and resources.
I support
Again, Member Rucker's comments about how important this is, but I just want to say, and I appreciate it being pulled off, is that there are such interest in getting this framework right, and I look forward to its development.
Thank you.
I'll just reinforce the timeliness of this.
There has been an evolution in thinking in the mathematics community as well, about the ways in which we use mathematics, about the ways in which areas of mathematics are integrated with each other,
development of and use of learning progressions and how people learn over time and how to think about the cumulative learning in mathematics, about the importance of data science.
We use that in every part of our lives, all of the time as informed citizens, when we're interpreting data, you know, statistics and scientific information.
And I expect we'll see a lot of
students beginning to model the exponential curves that we've been seeing in the newspaper all of the time lately as we're trying to think about, you know, flattening the curve and bending the curve.
And so I think this revision is going to bring a lot of that thinking to the table and a lot of good strategies for making mathematics meaningful and usable as well as
you know, cumulative over time.
So it's an exciting revision.
Are there any other comments or discussion before we go to our motion?
Seeing no hands, Member Strauss, were you going to make a motion?
I think Member Rucker wants to make a motion.
Okay, Member Rucker, please.
Sure.
This is Patricia Rucker, and I'm making a motion to
approved the staff recommendation as shown on the slides in the from the CDE staff.
Would you Janine would you put the slides up again with the recommendation on it.
Thank you.
May we please show the slide.
There we go.
Not that one that one.
So the recommendation would be, the motion and the recommendation would be to approve the revised timeline for the 2021 revision of the mathematics framework for California public schools, kindergarten through grade 12.
And that does include the added milestone meeting after the second public comment period for the IQC.
Terrific, thank you.
Second?
I'll second it.
All right, members trust.
Any further discussion?
Karen, do you want to call the roll call?
Yes.
Members Sung?
Aye.
Strauss?
Rucker?
Aye.
Patio-Bronson?
Pangelini?
Aye.
Navo?
Darling-Hammond?
Aye.
Burr?
The motion carries.
All right.
Excellent.
Thank you so much, Janine, and for all the work that's gone into this.
What I have next is the waiver consent calendar.
And if I'm in the right order here, the public comment slide should go up for the waivers.
We'll move to that waiver consent calendar.
We're first going to take up waiver items one through 12 and we'll open up the phone line for public comment.
Can we have that public comment reminder of the phone in number?
There we go.
So members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item may do so by calling this number and following the instructions thereafter.
And I know it takes a few moments for our avid callers to call in.
So Amy, do we have any public comments at this point?
We currently do not have anyone signed up for public comment.
OK.
I'm going to give it a little bit of wait time just in case somebody is trying to get through this process and hit all the numbers so we don't miss the opportunity for public comment if someone's trying to do it.
No one yet, Amy?
Still no one yet.
We'll go ahead.
We'll go ahead then.
Do I have a motion?
I'll move the waiver consent calendar.
Thank you, Member Byrne.
Do I have a second?
I'll second.
Second.
Thank you, Member Navo.
We'll hold a roll call vote.
Karen, can you call the roll?
Yes.
Member Sung?
Aye.
Sprouse?
Rucker?
Aye.
Patio Bronson.
Pangiolini.
Aye.
Navo.
Darling Hammond.
Aye.
Burr.
The motion passes.
Okay, my pages are
Potentially a little out of order because we had some changes, Karen.
Should I be going to agenda item 5 next or to the rest of the consent, the regular agenda items?
We do have one person now signed up for public comment.
Would you like me to open the phone line?
Yep.
Okay.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
I'm sorry, we can't hear you.
Could you please turn up the volume on your phone?
Okay, it looks like they have hung up.
That concludes public comment.
It must be a very complicated process.
So Linda, we're moving on to agenda item five next.
Okay, that's what I thought.
We had a little bit of changes in one of the agenda items.
So I'm just trying to be sure that we're
tracking properly.
There we go.
So item five is the consideration of funding determination for non-classroom based charter schools.
And this is going to be divided into two separate votes.
First, we'll discuss all of the schools except Kairos Public School 1635.
And the item will be presented by Stephanie Farland from the CDE, and I'll let her present the recommendation and the background.
There we go, there we go, good afternoon board members and Chief Deputy Gregson.
My name is Stephanie Farlan, I'm the Director of the Charter Schools Division and we are presenting item five which is a consideration of requests for determination of funding with reasonable basis mitigating circumstances by 26 non-classroom based charter schools.
The item consists of non-classroom based funding determinations by 26 non-classroom based charter schools and the spending percentages by the charter schools are detailed in attachment one of the item.
Just as a quick overview, the funding determination levels for non-classroom based schools are shown on the screen.
It's 100%, which is full funding, 85%, 70, or 0%, which would be a denial.
And the requirements for each of those funding levels are there on your screen.
The criteria for full funding
is 40% of its revenues of the charter schools revenues is on instructional certificated salaries and benefits, 80% of its revenues on instruction and instruction related services and that they maintain a people to teacher ratio that does not exceed 25 to one.
Those are the three conditions for 100% funding as follows.
And the 26 schools that are listed in attachment one have not met the three conditions which is why
They have requested reasonable basis mitigating circumstances.
Regulations permit the ACCS and the State Board to consider reasonable basis or mitigating circumstances by which to make a recommendation other than the one that results from the expenditure criteria specified.
As such, if a charter school does not meet the designated spending criteria, the charter school can submit mitigating circumstances for consideration.
And this is done on an annual basis.
A lot of those reasons for mitigating circumstances have to do with one-time expenses, unique or exceptional expenses, facilities, sometimes they get a private grant that ups their level of revenue that they were not expecting, and so that is why they ask for this.
These come in in February, the request for mitigating circumstances, along with all of the regular funding determination requests.
The funding determination periods, new charter schools, new non-classroom based charter schools shall be for two years.
Existing charter schools can be from anywhere between two and a maximum of five years and when we have mitigating circumstances we give two year
two-year periods, determination periods, that really allows us to go back in a fairly short amount of time to check in on the schools and to determine if those extenuating mitigating circumstances still exist.
Our recommendation today is for the California Department of Education, I'm sorry, the CDE recommends that the State Board of Education approve the mitigating circumstances requests and approve the determination of funding requests.
At the April 7th, 2020 ACCS meeting, the ACCS voted unanimously to approve the CDE recommendation of the mitigating circumstances requests.
Okay.
So, the public comment slide is up for people to dial in if they want to make a public comment.
But while we're waiting for members of the public to call in, I'll ask Sue Burr, our charter liaison, if she has any initial framing comments for us.
We'll then take any clarifying questions, public comment, and then go back to discussion.
I would just start with thanking Stephanie for her thorough presentation.
As she described this is a process that's been in place for many many years for non-classroom based schools.
There are lots of different circumstances which throw them out of those ratios those funding ratios that she described.
And this item was presented to ACCS really as a routine item and it and typically these items go on consent.
I know they were originally placed on consent so.
following public comment or any questions other board members might have, I would recommend that I would be happy to make a motion to move the department's recommendation.
Very good.
And are there any clarifying questions before we go to public comment?
All right, we're going to go on to, oh, it looks like member Navo, do you have a clarifying question?
Yes, real quickly on the ACCS
approval, you know, the advisory commission, are they, do they have representation of CTA there?
Yes, they do.
There's a teacher's representative on the ACCS.
And that was, and there was a unanimous vote out of there.
Yes, right.
Thank you.
Okay, so is there any public comment?
Yes, it looks like we have five people signed up for public comment.
I will open the telephone line now.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Hi, my name is Jared Austin.
I'm the co-founder and executive director of Kairos Public Schools.
Oh, I'm sorry, this is the wrong charter item.
If you don't mind waiting until the next item is up.
Okay, I'm speaking on item five.
Five B, which is the next item.
We divided item five into two parts.
Okay, I'm going to continue on a comment.
Good afternoon, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Eric, you sound like you're in a deep well, try to get close to the microphone.
Okay, I apologize.
I'm deep in my kitchen here.
So I want to speak in favor of the CSDC and unanimous ACCS recommendation.
We're very surprised that this very routine item came off of consent, particularly now during the COVID crisis.
These are the schools that are perhaps doing some of the most effective work in a distance learning environment and really leading the way here and we support the approval of this item.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Hi, this is Colin Miller from the Charter Schools Association.
Can you hear me?
We can hear you.
Yes.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board members.
We appreciate the opportunity to speak on this item.
I would associate myself with Eric's comments previously.
This is quite surprising to see this come up at this point in time as a concern.
These are quite common
adjustments that happen on a regular basis on your board item and are typically consent items.
I would note that the targets on the funding determination process are a very blunt instrument and therefore the mitigating circumstances are quite common for any minor adjustments in a school's budget or operations during the year.
This is not uncommon and it's quite necessary to reflect changes in budget through the year.
Things like facilities,
fires and floods, all the things that schools have noted in these items.
Also note that this was approved unanimously by the ACCS, so it is surprising to see this coming up the day of the state board item since this has been public for several months now.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Hi, my name is Miles Destin.
I'm speaking in support of DaVinci Rise.
Good afternoon State Board and CDE staff.
Thank you for CDE staff time throughout this process of working through our request for mitigating circumstances.
DaVinci Rise serves a homeless student population in L.A.
County.
We work very closely with Los Angeles County Office of Education to help serve that population.
They appear very supportive of our efforts in that regard.
We also to support
the founding and expansion of this program.
This school got a very large private grant of 10 million dollars that will be spent over the ensuing years and the last couple of years to found the program.
And so if you look at our specific dollar amounts in the table you can notice that this having a very large unusual effect upon DaVinci Rise.
We've spent 100 percent.
of our funding on certificated staff but overall it was the private grant that pushed us into non-compliance.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
My name is Lorraine Richards.
I represent California Teachers Association.
DTA is extremely concerned with the blanket approach to mitigating circumstances regarding non-classroom based charters funding determinations.
While there are many questions regarding the need for 100 percent funding for non-classroom based charters without mitigating circumstances becomes even more of a concern when we read the mitigating circumstances within the item.
Funding with mitigating circumstances at 100 percent should be the exception to the rule but for far too long it has been the default answer.
Currently there is a two year moratorium on non-classroom based charters.
And CTA believes that given the suspect rationales outlined by some of the requesting charters that spending precious state funds on them is not the best interest of the children of California.
In our letter dated May 6 CTA has outlined our recommendations for each NCB that has submitted a funding determination request with mitigating circumstances.
In conclusion CTA opposes the CDE's recommendation for 100
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Jason Sample with Gateway Community Charters representing Sacramento Academic and Vocational Academy, also known as SABA.
Today we stand to mirror a number of the concerns in terms of a seemingly routine item being pulled, but I want to express our appreciation, first of all, to the work done by CDE staff as well as ACS in recommending approval of this item.
SAVA serves some of the most vulnerable youth of the Sacramento area with our average student, excuse me, attending three high schools prior to arriving.
The bottom line, we are a safety net for our public education system.
The COVID crisis as all has really showed how vulnerable, how our vulnerable population is and how really much we need to be there to support them.
And so we continue to serve them through a high level of support through our distance learning and other programs being deployed very early.
So we urge your support of this item with the thought of the kids and the young people that we serve and the vulnerable students that we serve.
Thank you so much for your time.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Barbara Mandelbaum.
Butte County Office of Education.
Good afternoon.
I'd just like to draw attention to the Butte County schools that are on the list.
Butte County schools have had difficulty the past couple of years due to natural disasters of one sort or another.
Most recently the Paradise Camp Fire.
Schools have not been able to spend due to ongoing school closures resulting from the campfire and other emergencies.
And then in addition to that with the campfire there was a surplus of funding for fire relief.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Laura Mudge Olive Grove Charter School and Scott Warner CBO Olive Grove Charter School.
Good afternoon.
We are here today to thank you all for the CDE recommendation and ACCS recommendation for Olive Grove Charter School
We have five schools currently state board authorized.
Two of them are on this list.
We're here to answer questions you may have but our mitigating circumstances as you can all read really are a one-time mitigating circumstance based on the transition from one school to five schools.
And we just hope that you approve
this list of mitigating circumstances.
Thank you.
That concludes public comment for Item 5.
OK.
Now we're open for discussion.
Member Rucker do you want to.
Good job.
OK.
This is embarrassing.
Please mute your line whoever's still on the line.
We actually have one more caller that just called in.
Would you like.
OK.
Yeah let's let's take the last public comment.
Thanks.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation.
Oh, it looks like they just hung up.
Nevermind.
We are done.
All right.
So now we're open for discussion and Member Rucker, do you want to launch the discussion?
Sure.
I am particularly interested in the development of this item because as I was reading through it and I went
I probably I should not have read through all the details that were submitted because there was frankly some confusion for me about exactly what was being considered or what was not.
It wasn't really as transparent as it could be for all of the LEAs for all of the charter LEAs that actually that did receive the 100% funding determination today.
That is very good news.
But, yeah, I'm looking in particular at the 2 at the Excel chart that was provided by staff.
And looking at the, there were several that without the 100% funding determination without the consideration of mitigation, they would have the recommendation would have been denied and the rationale for why they would have been denied.
That's where I got confused because for a lot of them, there really didn't seem to be a qualitative reason to deny their, to recommend their denial without mitigation because it didn't seem to be changed.
I was raising the item and I wanted to have an opportunity to discuss the item because I don't think the narrative makes clear or explain exactly how the mitigation process informs the recommendation
from the department because I was very concerned about the ones that would otherwise be denied without the mitigation, but it didn't really clearly explain how those factors actually weigh in on making the final determination.
So that's the primary reason why I want to have the opportunity to discuss it.
And since we're sitting here on this distance, rather than digging into each one of those, I just want to raise that that needs to be clarified or at least made clear
Because I think that it creates a lot of unnecessary rancor and angst in the field about exactly what is being weighed and how the criteria for mitigation on exceptional circumstances or exceptional funding could work.
The one example I would give is an example of Butte County because of what happened with the fires and everything.
Those are very clear weighing exceptional funds and exceptional circumstances.
But a separate one, they simply want the mitigation because they want to open another site.
So those two different factors, while they can be considered exceptional, one looks very different than the other in the frame of understanding what mitigation is.
So I wanted to make sure we had the opportunity to talk about that and to understand how that criteria is looked at and evaluated.
So Stephanie, are you still there?
Yes.
Give us an explanation and then I'll go to Member Sun and Member Strauss who are also waiting.
Sure.
So when the funding determinations come into the office, they have the opportunity on those funding determination forms to declare that they have mitigating circumstances.
They know coming in that they don't meet the criteria for 100% funding.
So they, you know, let's just say they check a box to say we have mitigating circumstances and here they are.
I can tell you up front that it is never a blanket recommendation for all the mitigating circumstances schools.
We take them one by one on a case-by-case basis, which is really what the regs require us to do.
It is to be considered, everyone's to be considered on a case-by-case basis.
So, once we determine which of the funding determination requests are asking for mitigating circumstances, staff then goes into each of those requests to review their reasons.
I can tell you that we talk to each of those schools that are requesting mitigating circumstances often to ask for more clarification.
or more support for their request for mitigating circumstances.
It is never just a blanket approval.
We do spend a lot of time with these schools asking for whatever information seems to be missing or would support their request for mitigating circumstances.
And so you will see that there are several, there are several different reasons why these schools are asking for
for the mitigating circumstances basis.
And some of those are actually even cited in regulation in terms of facilities, one-time funding, natural disasters.
There are a lot of different reasons why they ask for these one-time funds.
And it's the other reason why we only give two years.
because we want to circle back with them in a short amount of time to see how they're doing.
But it is not, it is a case by case basis.
And we look at each one on its own merits.
Okay, thank you.
Member Sun?
Thank you.
I actually, I really want to appreciate Member Rucker for bringing up this issue because it has been
an issue when she talked about bringing rancor in the field and seeming to be confusing about which mitigations work and all that.
This actually has been a question among the charter community for a very long time, and there's been efforts for many, many years now to go back and take a look at these regulations with regards to non-site-based charter schools.
and trying to fix some of these issues.
So this process, it may be helpful to go back in history a little bit.
And my memory's a little bit vague now, but I believe this has been in place for almost 20 years, two decades now, this funding determination and the regulations.
And the
The 80%, 20% or 40%, all of that was pretty arbitrarily established.
And I also wanna point out that for traditional independent study schools, this does not apply.
This is only charter schools.
So in looking at these criteria, which are arbitrarily set, I know that over history, that because every circumstance is a little bit different,
These regulations have not worked.
I know there have been efforts and teams put together to try to work on this.
We've never made many changes in that.
So maybe it's time to take a look at it.
So this would be a way for us to review the current regs and see what is working and what is not working.
The other thing I wanted to say about this is that having
Knowing what the CDE staff and the charter schools division has to do in order to review this, it is not a blanket approach.
There's a lot of documentation for every one of these schools.
If they don't, if there's a question, they're asked to provide additional documentation.
It is quite a process.
And I'm very comfortable that if the Department of Education is recommending approval that they have done a lot of due diligence in making that recommendation.
All right member Strauss.
Oh, I want to thank member song for those comments and for member for talking about procedures and also Stephanie McFarland.
I believe that each of these cases were reviewed specifically for what the issues are.
And I also believe, and I appreciate today's public comments about issues shared about a grant about the fires.
And also, I think we need to remember that there's a pretty difficult, challenging group of students that these charters do service, not where you've got homeless kids, foster youth kids that have been in pre high school before they are there.
And so I want to say that our system needs the safety net for kids and.
As we continue to refine our charter processes, which the new law does guide us, I think each deserves its own review, and I believe that CDE did a thoughtful review of each of these issues, and also ACCS, so with the thoughtful review of the individual circumstances from CDE and ACCS, I would support a recommendation for approval.
All right, Member Neville.
You know, I agree with members Sun and Rutgers and members Charles, I do agree.
If something has been in place for 20 years, we probably need to re-look at that and make a concerted effort to make sure that the way that we're allocating funds is the way we should be allocating funds in this day and age.
But I also struggle right now changing the rules, what seems to be in the fourth quarter of this game.
And I think that with the unanimous,
vote out at ACCS and the representation variety of stakeholders there, my position is to support CDE's recommendation.
Amber Sun, are you waiting to speak again?
Yes.
I do hope that we might take the opportunity to convene a work group around these regulations because they are two decades old.
And I think that we
It is time to review and take a look at that.
All right, well, I think we've heard from everyone now.
Do I have a motion on this item?
President Bellingham, can I just answer a couple of comments that were raised and then I'm happy to make the motion.
Sure.
First, I appreciate Member Rutgers raising questions about the
Excel spreadsheet it's a little bit hard to figure out.
But I want to appreciate what the department has done in the item for each one of the schools.
They've provided quite a lot of description about what the request was what the mitigating circumstances are and the basis for their recommendation.
And just to reinforce what Member Sun said it's a pretty rigorous process that schools are expected to go through.
And the ACCS looks at these very carefully as well.
I also just want to clarify one of the commenters talked about there being a moratorium on non-classroom based schools that goes into effect in July and that's for new schools.
So it doesn't affect any of these schools that are being considered.
But apropos of a couple comments I do think that during the moratorium would be a perfectly appropriate time to decide what do we do going forward with non-classroom based schools and what what sort of funding structure should be in place.
Because it sort of runs the gamut as Ting mentioned.
Traditional independent study schools which are non-classroom based they get 100 percent funding.
And at some point in our legislative history we decided that farther non-classroom based schools should not only be treated differently with respect to funding but be put through all these additional hoops.
So I think now that we have kind of a pause starting for the next couple of years
It would be appropriate for us to really consider what does that mean going forward particularly given that not every every school district is running non-classroom-based schools out of necessity.
So with that said I would move the department's recommendation on this item.
Do I have a second.
I second.
Okay.
I think I heard members send first.
Any further discussion.
Karen will you call the roll for the vote.
Oh, I'm sorry, was there more discussion?
I just wanted to clarify that we are voting on just item 5 part one.
Yes, yes, OK.
OK, alright, yeah, ready for the has that understanding.
Go ahead, Karen.
OK, members Burr.
I darling Hammond.
I Navo.
I pangolinen.
I. Patia Bronson.
Hi.
Rucker?
Aye.
Strauss?
Sun?
Aye.
The motion passes.
OK, Ting, this is where you need to recuse yourself.
Just a reminder for the next item.
So this item will also be presented by Stephanie Farland.
Stephanie, please present the request by Kairos Public School Vacaville Academy number 1635.
Thank you.
The recommendation is the same as item 5, section 1, part 1, and that is that the State Board of Education approve the mitigating circumstances for Kairos Charter School and approve the determination of funding requests.
Is there anything else you want to say about it?
No, they were part of the original package, and so their mitigating circumstances were approved by the ACCS.
Right.
And we're doing this separately just for the purpose of the recusal.
Is there any public comment?
Currently, there's no one signed up for public comment.
OK.
Then we'll go ahead and see, again, Sue, would you like to give us some framing comments on this?
Yeah, just I will just stick with the ones I made on the first part of it, and I'm happy to make the recommendation and move the recommendation when you're ready.
All right.
Any other discussion?
Seeing no other discussion, would you like to make that motion?
Yes, I move the department's recommendation on Kairos Public Schools.
All right, and is there a second?
I move a second.
Thank you, Member Strauss.
I assume we're done with discussion.
Karen, would you like to call the roll?
Yeah, I'll just double check.
Amy, are there any public comments?
No, Kairos did not call back in.
OK.
Just double checking.
Member Sung?
She's with you.
That's right.
Sorry.
Strauss?
Aye.
Rucker?
Patio-Brownson?
Yes.
Panjalinen?
Aye.
Navo?
Darling-Hammond?
Aye.
And Burr?
The motion passes.
All right.
Thank you very much and thank you, Stephanie.
Ting, you can come back in.
Of course, how is she going to know that?
We're contacting her to let her know.
Okay.
She should be back any moment.
And we're going to go to the consent agenda.
This is the regular agenda items 6 through 11.
And we should have our public comment slide displayed.
There we go.
We'll see if Ting has gotten back yet.
We will be opening up the phone line for the queue for public comment.
So while we're doing that, we'll hope that Ting gets back here.
I'm back.
Yay.
Okay.
I know it takes a few minutes, but Amy, do we have any public comments at this point?
There are currently no people signed up for public comment on the regular consent items six through 11.
OK.
Just give and give it a tiny little bit of wait time just in case somebody like gets motivated to comment.
OK, still no public comment, right, Amy?
Correct.
No public comment.
OK, do I have a motion?
I'll move the consent calendar.
Thank you, and do I have a second?
I'll second.
Thank you.
We'll now hold a roll call vote.
Karen, can you call the roll?
Okay.
Members Sung?
Aye.
Strauss?
Rucker?
Aye.
Patio-Brownson?
Pangilinan?
Aye.
Navo?
Darling-Hammond?
Aye.
Burr.
The motion passes.
All right.
And this item 12 is our state board projects and priorities item.
We're going to leave that public comments slide up there.
State board staff recommends that we approve the preliminary report of actions minutes for the March 11 through 12, 2020 meeting.
And we will open the phone line for the queue for public comment.
We lost our public comment slide.
And while we're waiting for any members of the public to call in, do I have a motion from a board member to approve the March 11th through 12th, 2020 State Board of Education draft preliminary report of action slash meeting minutes.
This is Patricia Rucker.
I'll make that motion.
Thank you.
Do I have a second?
Second.
Thank you.
Amy, are there any public comments?
There are two people signed up for public comment.
I will open the phone line now.
OK, thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Hi, good morning.
My name is Jennifer Chow and I'm an attorney with the ACLU of Northern California.
I'm here to provide comment on item number 11.
The ACLU is a sponsor of the California Healthy Youth Act and a supporter of the adoption of the health rights.
We are currently taking public comment for item 12, state board priorities.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I thought this was for the consent item.
number 6 through 11.
Okay, we will allow you to go ahead and provide public comment for regular consent for item 11.
Okay, sorry about that.
That was confusing.
So, how much time do I have now?
One minute.
We'll start the time over for you.
Okay, thank you.
So the ACLU was a sponsor of the California Healthy Effect and a supporter of the adoption of the health framework.
We're calling to express our disappointment in the cancellation of the health instructional materials adoption process.
As you all know well over a decade has passed since the last health textbook adoption and since then there have been significant advances in health and science new changes in California's laws
as well as new challenges for access and equity within California communities.
The framework was a significant first step towards supporting educators to meet these new challenges.
So before you vote we hope you'll provide more information about how CDE will continue to build on that important work even despite the delay in materials adoption.
Now more than ever it's critical that California continues to lead through policies and values that are grounded in science and informed by public health.
Thank you.
And just to clarify, we are taking public comment currently for Item 12, State Board Priorities.
I will open up the phone line to the next caller.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
This is Elizabeth Wells, Communications Specialist on behalf of Planned Parenthood Affiliates of California.
We're also for Item 11.
OK.
Please proceed.
Planned Parenthood is one of the nation's leading providers of sexual and reproductive health care and the largest provider of sex education.
Last year we stood here representing the seven Planned Parenthood affiliates in California in strong support of the adoption of the health education framework.
As you know health education that is inclusive and comprehensive is critical for the health and well-being of Californians youth.
We are disappointed in the cancellation of the health instructional materials adoption process especially during a time when California is faced with a global public health pandemic.
The importance of widespread medically accurate health education during this time cannot be overstated.
While we continue to be grateful for the department's continued efforts to implement and roll out the health education framework, we look forward to hearing about the guidance and resources the department will make available to administrators and educators in place of the instructional materials adoption.
We thank you for your continued work to equip California's youth with the knowledge and skills needed to help them make healthy decisions about their body, their health, and their future.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Hi my name is Michelle Rivera with Act for Women and Girls.
I'm a sexual health educator here in the Central Valley and we are supporting the adoption of the health education framework.
We're grateful for the state board's leadership in developing
a robust guidance and inclusiveness of comprehensive health education.
We're hoping that the adoption of the instructional materials continue so that way that we ensure that all students across California do get the proper materials of those very important topics, especially around sexual health education.
We look forward to hearing more about the additional resources and guidance of the health education
It will take place of the instructional materials adoptions.
We will again like to thank you for the work you are doing and the support of the safety and well-being for all California students during this time.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Hello.
Hi my name is Alexis.
I'm a junior in high school in Woodlake California which is a rural town in Tulare County.
When the health framework passed last year it felt like a huge victory for Central Valley youth to ensure we would get medically accurate and inclusive health education.
I know that the framework already supports teachers to make sure that they are provided comprehensive sex ed in compliance with the Health Youth Act.
By and disappointed we will have to wait even longer to have textbooks that reflect the curriculum we need and deserve.
In the rural parts of our state we sometimes can rely on teachers to be unbiased when teaching sex ed.
And textbooks can be a vital resource to youth who don't have another means of getting accurate information.
I hope the California State Board of Education will continue to pursue getting textbooks into our schools that include the important information outlined by the health framework.
Thank you.
That concludes public comment for agenda item 12.
So much of that public comment was in fact, I think all of it was on item 11.
And I would like to ask Stephanie Gregson if she's there to just give us some background on the issue of the instructional materials for the health education framework.
So we just have that information.
Absolutely, thank you.
And we also have Shaneen Coates here, the director of the Curriculum Frameworks and Instructional Resources Division.
So I'm going to ask her to step up to the podium and provide a little bit more background information on the health instructional materials.
Thank you.
So although the state board took action today to cancel the 2020 instructional materials adoption due to low publisher interest, the state board and by the way we had one publisher that was interested in submitting materials and it would not have covered the entire K-8
However, the State Board can still adopt instructional materials based on the recently adopted framework at a later date if there is sufficient interest from publishers.
Of course, we would have to balance the timing of that with the other work of the Instructional Quality Commission.
Additionally, as was mentioned by the commenters, there are statewide efforts being made to support health education instruction.
A California health education website is currently in development as part of the statewide health education framework rollout project and will likely reference available instructional materials for all grade levels.
Thank you.
I think that's very helpful clarification.
And just to put a fine point on it, the issue here was textbooks, but there are other kinds of instructional materials, some of which are referenced as resources in the framework.
And as Shanine just noted, there are others that can be made available to the field.
So just so people understand, it's not a walking away from the question of providing guidance on instructional.
resources.
Now we're back to item 12, about which we had no public comment.
And is there any further discussion among the members of the board?
All right.
So I think we need a motion.
We did have a motion and a second motion.
OK, we got a little confused with the 12 and the 11 there.
Yes, and so I think we're ready now too.
If there's no further discussion to take a vote, yes.
Karen, give us the roll call.
Yes, members burr.
I darling Hammond.
I Navo.
I Pangellinan.
I Patio Bronson.
Karen, I wasn't at the March meeting, so I assume I should excuse myself from this.
Okay, you would to abstain?
Excuse me.
Abstain it is.
Rucker?
Aye.
Strauss?
Sun?
Aye.
Okay, the motion passes to adopt the minutes from the March meeting.
Okay, now I want to invite members to report on any liaison activities that are not related to any items on our May agenda.
And we've been going backwards and forwards in the alphabet.
We're going to start in reverse order based on last names.
Member Sun.
Oh, goodness.
Caught me off guard.
Sorry.
Yeah, no, no, no, that's fine.
That's fine.
So not too much to report.
We did approve the Perkins V application in March, as you all may remember.
And that is now currently with the governor's office awaiting his signature.
As regards to the Perkins funding, there has been flexibility granted by the Federal Department of Education resulting from COVID as with everything else.
So the California Joint Workforce, California Workforce Pathways
Joint Advisory Committee will be meeting tomorrow to discuss the flexibility items and also to look at what our local application for the Perkins funding moving forward will look like as well.
Terrific, thank you.
Member Vice President Strauss.
So a couple of things.
The State Literacy Task Force met on March 23rd and 24th.
It was a remote meeting to work on input for the State Literacy Grant.
WestEd did an amazing job.
I think we had about 70 participants in the task force.
So lots of breakout rooms focusing on early ed, elementary and secondary, really engaging process.
And you'll hear more about that coming up as the CD continues to work that through and bring it back to us.
IQC was on April 17 and Member Rucker and I both attended and they also did that remotely and worked so hard to deal with all the edits on the visual and performing arts and the world language framework.
both of which I'm now liaison to since our board members completed their terms.
So I'll let member records share a little more about that process because it was quite impressive considering it was remote.
And then a really big report I think is what the credentialing commission did April 23rd and 4th.
And so you might know that there's a lot of teacher candidates trying to finish up.
more than 26,000 teachers, principals, and other administrators, school psychologists, counselors, social workers, nurses, librarians, trying to finish and graduate, and suddenly there were problems getting their credential finished.
And so this was a lot of heartfelt testimony and thought by the Credentialing Commission to deal with areas that the commission has authority.
So some of it is legislative like certain tests, but some of it is things that the commission can waive.
So what the commission did was waive the 600 hours of student teaching that normally is required and allow university faculty where the student teacher is enrolled to decide how many hours.
A lot of them were almost done, and then they went remote.
And some of them are still working on it, but it's complicated.
So they also took a look at whether candidates had passed the TPA, the teaching performance assessment, to decide how much student teaching they would need.
They also had to deal with whether students had taken the CBEST for credential candidates that hadn't completed.
Some of the tests have been stopped, so we have to wait until the tests are restarted again.
And then they held a bunch of webinars to address all the different credentialing areas to share information that was completed up until this meeting.
So they gave the candidates a little more time to pass the test, but the law didn't allow suspending the test.
Some of the commission is working with the legislature to deal with some of the areas that are under legislative responsibility, but I think people felt like giving
looking at a longer induction program, looking at all the things that everyone is involved with so that teachers can start teaching and deal with deferring or modifying some of the requirements.
So I thought that was, it was a really impactful day with very passionate and heartfelt testimony.
Just the last comment, the math and science collaboration committees sponsored with grants that help with
standards implementation obviously is not meeting in person anymore no more community practice in person, but the science and math communities of practice have become resources to the state and they're having wonderful webinars on meaningful science experiences for elementary for middle for high school how to do you DL and how to do so.
CD's been in touch with them and they they will be providing statewide support as well as to their collaboration committee so I think in this pandemic time we are really reaching out to these communities of practice to try to provide us support in standards implementation and distance learning so I really thank everyone has been working so hard in that new format that can work.
Thanks member record.
Well, thank you.
I want to begin by giving a shout out as modeled by the department staff because this is teacher appreciation week.
I want to begin by giving appreciation to the hundreds of thousands of educators across the state to have.
stepped up to the challenge of implementing distance learning and alternative learning opportunities for their students in this transition, in this moment of great and urgent state emergency.
I recognize and I respect not only the work that you do,
But I stand in awe of the effort that you have put forth, not only to stay in contact with your students, but to make sure your students know that you are there for them.
On a personal note, I want to thank my own seventh grade math teacher, Mrs. Phillips.
She was, she stepped in and became the math teacher in my class at a time when the class itself was falling apart.
And she reinvigorated in me an appreciation and an enjoyment of math learning and learning math that I hold on to to this day.
Eileen asked me to talk to you a little bit more about the Instructional Quality Commission meeting that was held on April 17th.
Before I go into a little detail about that I want to remind everyone listening and my colleagues on the board that the next IQC meeting is going to be next week May 17th and the
agenda for the remote meeting has already been posted.
There were two very large items that were covered at the April IQC meeting, beginning with the World Languages Framework for California Public Schools, kindergarten grade 12, grade, kindergarten through grade 12.
The reason why we added the milestone meeting in the board action for the math item was important at this IQC meeting.
They spent a great deal of time going over the comments that came from the second 60 day public comment period.
And there was a great deal of detailed comments and discussion among the panel about the edits and corrections recommended.
One of the things that became clear for the commissioners as well as the people who took the time as stakeholders to submit comments was the need for the framework itself to recognize the audience of people who would be using the framework and would rely on the develop the guidance the framework provides in developing coursework as well as appropriate instructional sequences for students in the area of world languages.
They took a great deal of time to talk about, to debate, and to share their concerns in responding to the comments that were given from the second day, from the second 60-day review period.
The same thing is true for the language, for the arts education framework.
They also, as part of their deliberations, took time to review the summary of comments from the second 60-day review period.
The comments on arts were even more technical and even more in-depth.
While lots of us, when we talk, when students are polled and asked what their favorite subject is, it becomes, it is art.
Art becomes a different course of study and a different subject matter as you matriculate through the grades and get into high school.
And so there was a lot of attention paid to the development of the arts, the art strands and the work.
of teaching art and providing appropriate access instruction to all students, especially students who have particular needs as English learners for the lessons to be scaffolded and understanding what it means to create access for students with particular learning needs.
So it was a very, very frank and open discussion.
It was very interesting to listen to and to watch these dedicated educators dive into the concerns that were raised
and make adjustments and make agreements on adjusting and editing the framework to create a document I believe we will be ready to approve and accept when it comes to the board later this year.
The IQC, as I said, will be meeting next week and I'm looking forward to speaking with and seeing the commissioners again.
And then I'll close by saying I don't have other than
the items that I've already spoken to in earlier items that I've done on my liaison work.
I want to extend my thanks and appreciation to a lot of the local school districts that have invited me to sit and listen and participate in their webinars as they do their distance learning planning and their programs.
It was a pleasure for me to listen to your work, listen to your planning, listen to your thoughts, but also listen to you honestly struggle
and try to figure out what matters and what is important.
It's important to note that a lot of districts are being successful with this, but a lot of districts are frankly working out their struggles and doing them in appropriate and child-centered ways.
And this is an opportunity for all of us to appreciate our work, but also to think about how important we are connected as a community.
We're sitting apart.
But for parents and stakeholders in education we suddenly realize more importantly now why schools are important.
Why schools as a mission are important to all of us and why for parents and the students who go to those schools the work that we're attempting to do to help schools improve and develop and improve their mission it's big it became more important in listening to those conversations.
So I truly appreciate that.
That's the end of my report.
Thank you.
Member Patio-Bronson.
I'll actually pick up from board member Rucker's comments around how interconnected so much of the work of schools are with communities and lift up in particular in my home district of LAUSD, there are 60 grab and go centers across the 700 miles of LAUSD and they're serving with schools as the centers of community 50,000 meals a day.
at a time when kids across our state and their parents are reflecting that they are cutting back on meals because hunger has become a challenge as the health crisis.
And it's not something necessarily that is within the ambit of the state board's authority, but it is a critical role that schools are playing right now across the state to actually keep young children healthy so that when we get to some
version of normalcy that they'll be able to fully absorb all of the academic content and future life trajectories that we want and aspire for them to have.
In the spirit of appreciations also for Teacher Appreciation Week, and also I think this is Children's Books Week, I want to offer an appreciation for Anura Lawson, who is my older daughter's sixth grade English language arts teacher and
teaching 11-year-olds about the Socratic method with a role of Thunder Hear My Cry.
And I am so much enjoying watching all of the creativity that she's bringing into the classroom of figuring out new methods in time with a lot of kids.
And it actually still being a really rich, discursive conversation where people are exchanging ideas and living into these new mediums.
I also want to reflect on April 2nd.
The Early Childhood Policy Council had its very first meeting with co-chaired by Dr. Nadine Burke Harris, who's the Surgeon General.
And what was exciting was to hear and reflect some of the connections between early learning and the 12 system in those conversations.
I think in this context now where we are hearing so much about the role of childcare and early learning as an essential part of the workforce, there's a way in which it really brings up this idea that both early learning as well as K-12 has the primary function of providing educational benefit to the child, but also has a very important function of providing the capacity of parents to continue
And so we certainly have been hearing a lot about K-12 parents as well struggling to balance work life and home life in the same.
I'm broadcasting live from my garage because there are four different Zoom calls on at all times in my home with work calls and school calls.
But just
in some ways I think it actually lays bare how connected the early learning and K-12 are and how much we have to balance across these systems.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Member Pendleton.
I want to start off by also recognizing Teacher Appreciation Week and just thanking all teachers across the state who are trying to transition into distance learning and
Someone had a really interesting outlook on this time that I thought I'd share that it's the time to let go of perfectionism.
And I know that a lot of teachers are really hard on themselves that maybe they don't have these systems mastered perfectly.
But I can say from my perspective I know a lot of students' perspective that any form of communication and any effort on teacher's part is appreciated and it really helps create a sense of normalcy.
So I really appreciate that and I think this is a great week to celebrate that.
And I also want to say thank you to the.
California Department of Education for their diligence in really supporting districts.
And I know we're all going to get through this together.
Lastly something kind of exciting in partnership with an organization called Gen Up.
I've been working with districts students across the state in the creation of a California Student Board Member Association.
And its purpose would be to create a network of student board members and support them in highlighting student voice.
So I thought it was really interesting and I'm excited to see how that project progresses.
Awesome.
That's terrific.
Member Navo.
That was great.
Staying with the honoring teachers in the moment I have and I have a lot to share but I'll be brief.
Thirty nine years ago.
Yes Brianna.
Thirty nine years ago Miss Shirley Cox my fifth grade teacher told my football coach this boy is not going to another practice until he learns to read.
And she saved my life.
So in honor of the late Shirley Cox I just want to give a big shout out to her for standing up for against me and everybody else and making sure I learned what I needed to learn.
So I miss her.
With that being said I do want to give a shout out to state board on the organizing the virtual board meeting and I really liked the quick reference guide they provided and I'm hopeful that will be part of the regular meetings because it was very helpful.
I want to highlight the system of support and trying to take an opportunity to just the system of support as it pertains to supporting our local educators during this time of crisis has been very busy.
And I think it's important to make sure that everybody understands that.
The opportunity to talk about this to share what's happening is not just a CCEE conversation, but it's a CDE conversation, a county office conversation, GeoLEAD conversation, a SELPA LEADS conversation, AXA conversation, a CSBA conversation.
It is all hands on deck.
And I want to give some credit to some important things, at least highlight some important things that are happening without belaboring all of the details.
But I think under this particular time, a few things that jump out is CCE's work to shift to distance learning and instruction in a virtual environment.
That focus, along with the focus around distance and blended learning to support the field and build partnerships, develop training tools and supports has been incredibly helpful in partnership with our consortiums, Orange County, Kern County, San Bernardino School District.
In addition, CDE, their efforts in making sure that we have devices and connectivity and
That was an all hands on deck in terms of getting the survey that CDE needed out.
ACSA and CCE and a number of others pushed that out so that the information could come back to CDE in a way that would allow them to respond to the field needs and needs of families.
I think that's a great example of the way that the system of support is pulling together and finding their own groove without a lot of time to create an articulated plan.
Everyone is complementing one another's strengths at this time.
And I think that's what we envisioned when we saw the system of support.
And I think in a time of crisis, it brings out these opportunities where entities can work together
and provide support such as the playbook on teaching and learning that is coming out of a consortium of work led by CCEE Riverside County and San Diego County Office of Ed, the rapid response toolkit that CCEE and WestEd put together, the work of the SELPAs to highlight distance learning for EL students with disabilities,
And I think there are a couple of people in the system of support when you have times of crisis and leaderships rise to the surface, you have Sandy, your county office of ed really doing some work around the COVID-19 planning assumptions guide that has been widely circulated across the state to give people, locals, things to think about, how to plan.
You have Sandy Lyon, superintendent out of Palm Springs,
who implemented a three-phase distance learning program that I think is becoming more readily available and highlighted across the state as something to think about.
I can't underscore enough the opportunity
we have to take in this time to really bring all the entities together to support local educators who are boots on the ground, local families, students, and teachers to do this work.
And I think that this has highlighted a lot of energy pushed out into the system to actually bring some focus and some support and some trainings that is so desperately needed.
So Board Member Hammond, President Linda Darden-Hammond, I just wanted to make sure
There is a lot to share but I want to just take that moment to just highlight the integration of all entities in the system to support to support students and their families.
Terrific.
Thank you.
Member Burr.
I think it's your turn President Darlene Hammond.
Well I'll just say a word at the end but I had a chance at the beginning.
So you actually have heard about my work already through the accountability items and the charter items.
I'll just do a shout out to a couple of teachers
The most important teacher in my life is my daughter who's an 8th grade history teacher and she's activities director.
Ting happens to know her well.
She's doing modeling what board member Patia Bronson said trying to teach from her home and raise two children aged 1 and 4.
So a great deal of appreciation for her.
As far as my own teacher I'd give a shout out to Mr. Barber who was my 12th grade English teacher.
and taught me how to write.
And to this day it's one of the most important skills I think I have.
So I have a deep appreciation and I also miss Mr. Barber.
So with that I will turn it over to President Darlingham.
Thank you.
Well just continuing the theme of gratitude I will also shout out to my daughter Elena who is a teacher at home with a two year old.
as well, and everyone who's doing that knows what that means.
Kim, I noted that you said you're speaking to us from your garage.
Is that right?
Yeah.
I wish you could find a quiet moment.
But you know, so many people are doing so much good work.
My own kindergarten teacher, Mrs. Bowen, I will recognize, who got me started in public speaking, actually, in kindergarten, because that was part of what she wanted kindergartners to do.
A lot of the work I've been doing for and with the board and with CDE has been around the many areas where we're getting guidance out.
And I do want to acknowledge all of the members of the state board staff and the CDE staff who have just been so diligent and vigilant about getting the
guidance out to the field that has enabled and the resources that have enabled a lot of the work to go on as that said has been a joint collaborative effort across.
Many organizations in the state as well as agencies of government and it's been wonderful to see how people just rolled up their sleeves and really work together.
I do want to also acknowledge and thank Christian right to has
She has begun a process of transition from her position in CDE, where she has ably led the special education division, and she'll be going to the Sacramento County Office of Education.
We intend to continue to bother her regularly.
She makes that transition.
She's done enormous work in the state that has been of great, great value.
And as I say, she's not going far, so that's a good thing.
And Kai Jackson, who is moving back, I think, to San Diego.
And he did wonderful work around equity and around teaching and learning.
So we will miss them both.
And we are grateful for their work and that of all the folks have been rolling up their sleeves to get us through this period of time in a way that I think, while it has
certainly raised for us a lot of the equity gaps that we know have been there and that are so much more obvious in times like this.
There's also mobilized so much good effort to solve those problems.
So I'm hopeful that we can continue to build on that momentum.
And with that, I think we want to move on to agenda item 13, which takes us back to the public comments slide, our favorite slide of the day.
If we could get that up again.
Yeah, so just if you wait a minute, we'll put up the public comment slide.
I think we do have a couple of people already queued up too.
Okay.
And I'll just remind folks that public comment is invited on any matter that is not included on the printed agenda.
So we are going to open the phone line for public comment with the dial in number and the access code.
And I'll just
as see if Amy has some folks queued up and ready to speak.
I do.
There is one person signed up so far for a public comment.
I will open the phone line now.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Yes good afternoon.
This is Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
I would like to ask that the superintendent the department and board issue guidance to local educational agencies on using social emotional approaches
to returning to school in any form addressing the loss of learning and assessing the needs of students.
Even though formal assessment is waived and the dashboard accountability system is suspended for 2020 the state still has an obligation to oversee schools.
We appreciate the guidance released thus far but there needs to be guidance focusing on the mental health impact of the coronavirus on students.
A needs assessment from our community-based organization partners underscores that social emotional needs must be addressed as schools conduct distance learning, continue to find and locate students, assess learning loss, and reopening this summer and fall.
Guidance from the department on this is critical and it is needed.
Thank you.
Looks like that concludes public comment.
Well, that's a good note on which to end.
I hereby adjourn the May 2020 meeting of the State Board of Education.
It's great to see you all and we'll see you in July.
Thank you.
Bye bye.